[Music]
there's no time
[Music]
the time is thirteen o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody it's friday
what was what
saying hi to the damn cat out there on
her back porch
well you know i love everybody just like
i love pokey all right yeah today
it's gonna be a fun show because we're
talking about the raelians
the riley the raelians there's a there's
an umlaut in that [ __ ] it's kind of like
going to see the lizarium
over there south park lazarian this
arium
yeah i feel like the word lazarium
should also have an umlaut yeah listen
actually maybe two or three oh lounge
yeah just saying
back when lasers were high-tech man i
remember going to see the
thank you nicodemus what'd he say
nothing he's just like a little
he's giving us a really nice super chat
and there's a little i love all the
little dancing little
yeah thank you very much what is that
little thing it's like a little i can't
it's funny
that you got that you got that okay now
i see it yeah sometimes i have to
have to like reload my super chats yeah
you say that everything yeah
they stick yeah see dj maniac said if
you need to oil it anyway
i don't care if there's an umlaut you
know it's [ __ ] metal that's right
so i guess that's why that's why uh the
raelians have the umlaut well that's the
dude's name that found it it's not his
real name that's the name that the
aliens gave him and that's his story
well i was telling him just i was like i
as much as i love doing like the true
crime shows and [ __ ] like that
more money too it's kind of nice to do
um
shows about thank you david woo the show
begins yeah that's right it's friday
y'all
it's kind of nice to do shows about
stuff that's not
uh soul crushing uh so then that way i
don't feel so bad about like making
jokes and stuff
because i mean as what they're saying we
look great yes because
yeah i finally because remember i shaved
part of it but then like i left this
this here and then like last night i was
like you know what [ __ ] it it's just i
thought it looked too messy
so it's just kind of like i can't do
anything with that so because i've just
kept tucking it behind my ear so i was
like [ __ ] i'm just going to shave it
off i got to get in the proper
launch position you're going to where
you're going proper launch position
but i'm i'm piloting the spacecraft okay
he's pilot pilot in the spacecraft he's
got my don't pull that out too far
yeah um well i don't know i've never
pulled it out that far
so it's like i wouldn't want everything
falling onto the floor me finding out
tila says i'm tired as hell but i'm
going to hang in there as long as i can
we're tired
me too i for whatever reason i woke up
at [ __ ]
quarter to six this morning and could
not go back to sleep yeah to save my
[ __ ] life
so you know and right like 10 minutes
before we did the show we realized that
we didn't have
all that much booze left i mean we have
some
but not as much as usual but i was like
well that's okay because
if i had too much booze i'd probably
just like fall asleep
[Laughter]
so this should be a fun show it's good
to see everybody
back if you weren't with us uh last time
t you were slack
she was traveling she was second it's
good though it's good to have the
regulars back
it is yeah yeah david june says i'll
steal jenny from tom one of these days
she's gotta experience a real man
i think it's [ __ ] i think it's funny
when you boys it's a throwdown it's a
throw down
it's going to be a dick down you see
who's got the biggest dick
quack quack whoever's more well and down
gets them gets to hit the other
[Laughter]
maximum security prison i just that's
like how you got you all try to man up
on me like that
that's [ __ ] great i just want you to
want to be you want to be known
none of y'all could ever be a man next
to me you put you stand next to me it's
not it doesn't even look like two
minutes like man and woman
if i get some of that it's not even gay
all right it's straight up heterosexual
okay yeah yeah i don't even have to be
guilty so man it wasn't even like i was
gay there
again that's his story and he's sticking
to it
[Laughter]
yeah it's relativity it's sexual
relativity
see man your [ __ ] are already
starting me off this [ __ ] early and
[ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] changing my hair my
changing my head all right well i feel
like
we'll put [ __ ] wig on well since
we're talking about the rhyllians
um raelians resilience whatever they are
since we're talking about them i feel
like the sexual tyrannosaur hat
at least at this juncture is probably
is probably uh apropos because that's
kind of one of the main things that
people know about this
cult religion whatever you want to call
it uh is the whole free love thing
although i mean you know there there's a
lot more to them there's you know they
believe in aliens too
honestly i gotta say um
the more i looked into these people like
they're weirdos for sure
but they don't seem to be
um dangerous weirdos i could be wrong
about that
they have some like weird-ass beliefs
but a lot of their beliefs i'm just kind
of like ah
okay that's cool i can read it i can
agree with that
yeah so it's like i don't know i just
kind of feel like there's not
there doesn't seem to be like a lot of
nefarious [ __ ] going around it's not
like scientology where they're like
locking people in holes and having
people murdered allegedly
uh and [ __ ] like that it did not that i
know of i mean you know that might be
going on zachary shows up oh if it's a
dick down i'm up for them yeah what
all the gays someone say they're always
[ __ ] right and then tila's in there
[ __ ] talking to me specifically stop
calling me out you make me sick
yeah mango said is it my eyesight or is
the camera out of focus
it's uh it's doesn't look out of focus
on my end so it must be just you you're
going blind
yeah it happens it happens to the best
of us yeah it's like how drunk are you
already
yeah now david says that we're gonna
share we're gonna share it
man oscar says tom and jim would be an
ideal aunt and uncle i wouldn't be a
cool uncle
yeah you would i don't but i have any
siblings so i'll never be uncle
unless i get married into a family well
yeah i got siblings
i got three of them and one of them
already has a bunch of kids well not a
bunch of kids yeah
okay now zach's in here [ __ ] showing
off he goes
tom if it's if it says anything i want
spain to beg the black dude
once and even he said i was big
oh my god you mean deep right
[Laughter]
roger dodger said can we start the
measuring contest at negative
three inches like some people do like a
handicap like that you gotta watch out
for zach man he's one of them [ __ ]
power bottoms
slap a [ __ ] like that you go [ __ ]
falling on your back like that he jumps
up in the air and comes down on your ass
first
i once saw him do that to a [ __ ] fire
hydrant
that's yeah he likes him yeah [ __ ] it
right
had that [ __ ] swelled up [ __ ]
vlogger head on the end of it
[Laughter]
he likes him irregular shapes
you didn't know about zach zack's booby
master
he's a booty bastard [ __ ] hitch he's
like a whole wave of ass like a tsunami
like a pig i can't talk tsunami why
[Laughter]
glorious bastard says good name by the
way what's the topic we're talking about
the
aliens the the ufo ufo cult but like i
said because
uh what most people know about them is
the free love thing
and the aliens thing and also the human
cloning thing
um so you know so all of those topics
are uh
you know that's that's totally on the
table
zach's trying to fight back into this
twisting mind game of homosexuality
where he's trying to convince me that he
was a top
you could never be a top not not when
i'm around not when i'm walking to earth
you could never get down
not while you're and then other people
are back they're saying we need to have
a [ __ ] show about sasquatch
you know i believe i we did a cryptid
show like a long time ago
to do a sasquatch but i don't think
we've done like uh just a dedicated
bigfoot sasquatch
show right because on what did we talk
about i think we talked about the
sasquatch and maybe the skunk ape
on the um on the uh cryptid show but we
it was like a variety show of cryptids
see here's the thing man well [ __ ] maybe
i'm
maybe i'm speaking too soon but
what does that ever stop i know i'm
gonna get ready to talk about my ass
[Laughter]
out of all the [ __ ] weird [ __ ] all
out of all the paranormal years back
when i was a kid
i would have thought that bigfoot would
have been the most likely
until i saw poltergeist not ghost real
poltergeist there's a difference
and poultry guys [ __ ] freaked me and
i would have thought had you told me
about poultry guys
when i was a kid i wouldn't have
believed that you know you know what i
mean
i would i would well actually no maybe i
would have
if you'd asked me what was most likely
and least likely i would have put
poltergeists way down at the bottom of
the list of being likely
you know yeah i kind of feel like
sasquatch would be more likely to
sasquatch and age
if we're going that way sasquatch and
aliens i would think would be likely
as i've gotten older now know more a
little bit more about ecology in the
human mind and
it's less likely that just sasquatch
i mean they got some badass spy
satellites that can see an individual
person walking around at night just from
the heat just their heat images
you'd think that they'd pick them up you
know well there's a sasquatch you know
some person well there he is right there
hey little guy
who's that out in the middle of nowhere
out there in [ __ ] canada
who is that that's a goddamn sasquatch
zoom in carl
get that on tape yeah you think that
they would but
i mean because you can see deer through
satellites true so
i don't think so but we'll talk about it
later
tyler says fried chicken at 13 o'clock
life is good
fried chicken that sounds good that's
right pour some
um pour some syrup on it put some maple
syrup on it or honey it's good
or honey just now put maple syrup in a
bowl
and then just dump it that's the way a
real redneck
fish it's gonna get out the mrs
butterworth
yeah melt butter in it
no i actually just put butter on the hot
chicken and then
dump it i like your juice okay yeah yeah
i'm imagining it
i'm so [ __ ] the food sitting there
i'm just like
getting some of that getting some of
that mrs butterworth's on there or
you know maybe real maple syrup and
eating it like that hell yeah
and then i'm using a waffle as a napkin
and then eating it yeah yeah gross
tom's the skunk ape that was the big
joke yeah
because this table manners are atrocious
and also he smells
yeah my table manager's not that bad no
i know i'm just kidding well
well that's i was saying because you
like were wiping your mouth through the
waffles
yeah eating it you know what i mean um
but yeah especially now that you're on
testosterone you're like really like a
skunky
yeah maniacs add some cayenne pepper to
that [ __ ] water
well see now to the maple syrup that
sounds good
cayenne pepper in the maple syrup mm-hmm
see there you go he didn't even think of
that
that's a good one yeah i'm gonna come up
with that victor says maybe
sasquatch are normal people most of the
time and changed into sasquatch like
aware sasquatch
sure that's a possibility well that
would explain why you don't see them
because they're just like regular ass
people most of the time and then like
when it's the full moon or whatever just
they just go out and but they don't like
eat people or nothing like werewolves or
they just like walk around in the
canadian wilderness
and occasionally get filmed by rednecks
all right so do we even have
any shout outs i don't think we do
actually oh i will say that i
finally finally made an intro
for the side tracks show for christ's
sake because remember how for months
every time we do a sidetrack show on
wednesday i'm always kind of like huh
and it's
like it doesn't have an intro and it
feels really weird i finally did like
make a little intro for that so
there we go and also i made a little
outro for this show
with like credits on it with all the
patrons names and stuff like that so i
thought that was kind of neat
if i if we get to the end of the show
and i'm still sober enough to remember
to play it
then you know that'll be good camp guy
he came up with something man it sounds
very interesting i'm gonna have to do it
in a complete investigation
he's talking about wings right yeah
indian wings
with the clean rice vinegar dipping
sauce with ginger and sambal
mmm yeah i'm gonna look into that
indian wings indian chicken wings
but you see i'd usually take chicken
wings and bump them up to dinosaur wings
get rid of the chicken wing and then
just replace it with a damn drumstick
that's what i call it and uh because you
can get drumsticks power per pound
cheaper than wings
yeah there's a lot more there's a lot
more meat there
i do chicken wings were a [ __ ] a
marketing [ __ ]
genius you take the worst least
worthwhile piece of the damn chicken to
turn it into a delicacy
well yeah i remember there was a time
when i was a kid when chicken wings
weren't worth anything
it was like buying gizzards you know or
chicken hearts they're not worth
anything
although you love chicken hearts i love
chicken hearts
yeah i consider eating a little chicken
thank you esther thank you very much
love the show thank you very much zach
asked if we were into the tomb raider
games
thomas i like them yeah tom likes those
i've played the new ones though
what was the last one you had i remember
watching you play it man you're asking
me all these kind of things it was the
one where stop asking me questions yeah
stop asking me questions
[Laughter]
it starts off she's uh in the in a boat
and then she gets up on land and then
she ends up in the ends
[ __ ] going underneath the water and
finding all these norse runes
big old norse statues and tries to find
she's trying to find
i love his excalibur or whatever and uh
her friends after and she's got turned
into a demon
it's pretty good man i hate when i'm
looking for somebody that got turned
into a dude
i liked legend though too yeah yeah from
the you know from the 2000s legend
and then there there's a bunch of them
thank you david
love this show but i'm poor that's you
know
it happens everybody's poor
uh well some of the raelians i don't
think they're poor
no well because like the the dude that
runs it like people buy them houses and
[ __ ]
yeah well uh the whole ufo cult is a
good angle
you can make a lot of money with that
that you know elrond hubbard you know
[ __ ] he made scientology one of the
richest cults you could get
weirdest richest strangest cult yeah
it's a ufo corporation ufo mind control
corporation
and uh they said that when
when elrond hubbard was around they they
liked him you know they liked the cult
but it's
david miscavige has kind of [ __ ] it up
over the years it it's not a
it's definitely it's not as fun as it
used to be
here comes scavenge you ruined
everything yeah well if you could have a
ufo cult and keep it fun
i kind of feel like the more i the more
i know about the raelians
um i kind of feel like that
you know like i said they have some kind
of like weird-ass beliefs
but they seem to be having a good time i
don't think anybody's like they're
against their will
or well you said free love so there's an
incentive right there well yeah that's
what i mean
you know they and they seem to be like
pretty cool and pretty chill with
everybody
you're the cult leader you're sitting
there you're like yes right
send me all your money now start [ __ ]
see who wiggles right now cult of tom
send me all your money
[Laughter]
yeah i have decreed it so i had decreed
that you all need to get down
get the [ __ ] down with each other
everybody big pile right
in front of me yeah i [ __ ] dressed up
like moses proclaiming [ __ ]
i got a staff you know my rod and my
staff my ride and my staff
y'all need to throw down
sure yeah behind me they got the big i'm
on stage and they got a big old [ __ ]
fake volcano behind me and [ __ ] smoke
and [ __ ] lightning and [ __ ] like i've
been up at the top [ __ ] getting the
ten commandments
come back down you tell them all to get
busy you know what's weird is that
i it only just occurred to me when you
said the word volcano yeah but it's like
how you know how scientology has the
whole xeno in the volcano
thing well it just occurred to me that
the raelians the story that the dude
tells about founding it was like also
happened at a volcano although he didn't
say he just said that he was at the
volcano and then like he saw the aliens
they'd come out of the
well they're ripping off they're ripping
off um um
the old testament they're ripping off
yeah
yeah and like i said if you like read
through like what they believe they
basically well they basically believe
that the bible is true as far as it goes
but
not in the way that people think it is
uh camp guy says i want to send
something is there a way like a p.o box
just uh message me later and i'll send
you like just
our mailing address that's what we
usually do because we don't have a po
box we should probably get one one of
these days but
j maniac sent us a super chat thank you
very much bro oh wait i guess thank you
very much dj maniac
tom cruise really liked that ship sure
[Laughter]
tom cruise should have gone into space
with bezos yeah
where's sandra sandra hasn't shown up
yet oh yeah we wanted to see what her
her uh funny name was you know that
she's gonna have a funny name
she always changes her name like every
single time we're there yeah
so uh do you want to like get started on
this or
do you like have other things that you
need to discuss
because i can't really think of any new
like we haven't had any new developments
uh this week no new patrons no nothing
like that so
taylor did you uh you still watching um
spartacus
tila also says that they say uh
lemirians live inside mount shasta
lemurians yeah
it's like
yeah i think i wrote an article about
that a couple years ago yeah
like all that all those lost continent
type stuff right
sandra is busy with mango peanut butter
yeah probably yeah
victor says get a p.o box in case you
get some stalkers
i'd stalk you but i work too much you're
not we're not worried about stalkers
[Laughter]
i could take care of hundreds of stuff
y'all need to worry about me okay i'm
not worried about you
and i mean you know yeah i'm not really
all that worried about either
because most i mean you guys like i
pretty you know i feel like i know you
guys even though i've never met you guys
in person but
i was like i don't i don't think anybody
i mean you never know but
you never know you get like some weird
ass troll like we had on wednesday if
you guys missed that that was super fun
although i didn't see much most of what
he said because like
like i wouldn't have cared anyway but i
think zach like [ __ ]
kept shooting them down it was just kind
of like [ __ ] we're
talking about something yeah you're
gonna
you're gonna do your uh i'm gonna have
to become michael caine we're gonna
okay so michael caine's going to weigh
in on this
on this ufo religion situation
yeah well i put this one on whenever i
put this wig on i actually become more
intelligent
is that how that works yeah i've noticed
it several times can you explain like
the science behind that
no i don't it's it's it i have no idea
some kind of osmosis situation or it's
just for some
reason i put this one on and i just
become [ __ ] smart
real [ __ ] smart this is like a mad
scientist wig
oh okay there i guess i kind of feel
like maybe though
the mozart slash thomas jefferson wig
would be the go-to
for smartness well it has it hasn't
[ __ ]
you know overtaken me yet okay yeah but
well we have no
we only just like that's a big that's a
wig of authority
not so much intelligence yeah those are
two different
yeah this is a wig of intelligence
and insanity okay yeah i like that
is he [ __ ] you i told you
david june says i guarantee if you show
up at their door stalking them
tom and jenny would invite you in for a
drink and booze then he'd kick your ass
be the last they see you
[Laughter]
tom you need the hand to go with yeah
well it's back there on the
on the bookshelf yeah the way we have a
separate handbag
yeah there it is yeah just back there uh
amanda marie hey tom and jenny tom
looking good with the hair i know it's
beautiful
wig becomes antenna maybe that's what it
is
i don't know what it is it kind of like
sticking up it's like
all the all the filaments are like
bringing in all the entities
[Laughter]
look [ __ ] smart i look [ __ ] super
smart
i can [ __ ] super smart white boy this
is also kind of relevant because i don't
know if you
know this but the raelians believe
that the world should be run by what
they what do they call a geniocracy like
a geography
geniuses yeah yeah only smart people
should
should run the [ __ ] yeah if see [ __ ]
oh man that is saying that [ __ ] uh
esther says i'm dr jekyll mr hyde
yeah that's probably true um
i think you're all high no hi you're
only like that much
jekyll
[Laughter]
just depends on my mental state of the
tie trail yeah
yeah thomas and gloria's bastard said uh
you mentioned russell related to shirley
temple
when russell crowe jenny was there with
me when russell crowe
turned into [ __ ] uh mr hyde i went
along with him on that journey i was
like
yeah yeah
yeah that's right you know you know he
started taking me and she said she's
pulling me back
you know pulling me back that was near
one of my injection times too
he had to take an injection to shut him
down yeah it's the other way around i
put it in jail yeah then you start like
hiding out
yeah yeah well no i think what it was
was he started taking the potion
to turn him into mr hyde and then after
a while it started doing it
spontaneously
so then it was kind of like yeah he had
to have that thing in his [ __ ]
remember he had that
bracelet that yeah that's right that
[ __ ] injected something to shut him
back down and turn him back into mr jack
a lot of people didn't like the
[ __ ] jackal yeah a lot of people
didn't like the moment i did not i liked
it
although i will say that russell crowe i
liked the rust i liked the
jekyll and hyde they should have made
the whole movie about him that would
have been good well they tried it
we're getting sidetracked no yeah what
else is the whole the whole thing about
that movie
was that they took those classic silver
screen characters and tried to turn it
into an action movie they had tom cruise
in it
see you that's what i said that is
[ __ ] ridiculous that's a dumb idea i
liked it
i i liked the attempt i could watch
three or four of those
i would like it's still kind of like
what was that one of the werewolves
it's kind of like underworld underwear
kind of like underwear
[Laughter]
you know underworld remember that one
yeah i wasn't crazy about that one
either but it was
a long long time it was all right i just
didn't really remember it was like that
one and like van helsing and it was just
kind of like all those
90s and early 2000s like
horror action movies i was just kind of
they all seemed very samey
then it's kind of like the league of
gentlemen yeah yeah yeah i like that
almost good but not really that's it
yeah see that's the problem i had with
it it's like it just seemed like it
i wanted it to be good like sometimes it
was like a good concept
but then it's just like they all seem to
like blend together
now i'm pretty sure that i saw all of
them but i couldn't tell you like what
happened in one and it wasn't
like i confuse all of them i saw i went
back and looked at certain scenes from
the mummy and realized that
well it's all style and no substance
there's very the dialogue is very
shallow it's
like i said it's just a spectacle
there's not much there story-wise
yeah it's just like dangling a shiny
object in front of
which is that makes a lot of money
evidently but i think the crowds are
sick of that i think people have figured
that out who is it that calls it that i
can't remember like what site calls the
calls movies like that jingly keys
because like he's like just a shiny
object in front of a baby's face tila
said tom with the glasses you remind me
of dr frederick frankenstein and the
young frankenstein
it's alive alive that's what you should
do that would be like super funny
we need van helsing versus cryptids no
why i'd probably watch that
there's a lot of like really cool
cryptids that they really need to make a
movie about
you know instead of like recycling all
the same monsters all the time just
saying
so you're ready to like talk everybody
talk about this you're talking about
aliens yeah well the first aliens
raelians oh
raelians railing against the aliens
rage against the machine rail against
the aliens
oh my god that should they should come
they have a band called rail against
aliens that's like a rage against the
machine cover band
except they cover all the rage against
the machine songs
in alien context oh my god somebody do
that like right now
i'll buy all your albums so uh so let's
talk about
the dude like i said i kind of feel like
before i started researching this show
the only thing i knew about them was you
know it was something to do with ufos i
knew about that cloning thing because i
remember that
when that was on the news because they
said hey we cloned a baby um
which i don't think they did but
whatever and um
and then the whole like free love thing
now as i said
i kind of thought i had the perception
that they were kind of like
a cult because of i don't know like
there's so many cults and i get them all
confused so i'm like is this the one
that had like all the [ __ ] underage
brides well you know there's more than
one that had that
but like i said this one seems like
it's pretty much okay
i mean in the sense that any kind of
weird religion like that can be okay
they don't seem to be
horribly exploitative they don't seem to
be keeping people against their will
they don't seem to be going after
underage girls that i know of
uh there are some controversies and [ __ ]
like that but it doesn't seem like
anything
like really really bad you know what i
mean like most of their beliefs and
stuff
i'm kind of like yeah okay that's fine
it's just it's nothing like really
horrifying but i don't know i thought
they were like really interesting
nonetheless
so let's talk about the dude
that started this whole uh thing
his name is claude vorellong vorelhol
something like that that's front he's
french french oh [ __ ] what
means did i put my french wig on
oh you should have known you didn't
realize he was french no he's french
i didn't know he was french that changes
the whole game that changes dynamics
it's too bad you don't have a beret yeah
all right there you go now i'm just
instantly [ __ ]
[Laughter]
instantly [ __ ] sort of hold on man i
gotta
do the accent or something can you do
like an accent
when i'm ready you could have worn like
a stripy shirt and had like a big
baguette or something i don't know
i can't do a french accent i can't
either i'm not even gonna attempt
yeah there we go i took french for like
four years i still remember some of it
but not that much
yeah so uh yeah so this dude missing
claude
club jean-pierre
[Laughter]
mondew but yeah so so uh
claude so he's born in france obviously
now according to him i guess he wasn't
raised like super religious like i guess
he grew up in his uh
grandmother's house and she was an
atheist
and then like his mom was also an
atheist and his dad was jewish but was
also
like not really that much of a believer
weirdly though
he got sent to catholic boarding school
which i don't know if that was just like
a regular thing that they did
even though he wasn't a catholic maybe
it was the only school that was around
or whatever
so he didn't go into like a catholic
school um for a little while
but then um at when he was about 15
years old
he actually ran away from the boarding
school
and hitchhiked to paris
and there he was essentially for three
years he was a street musician
so um so he's kind of like playing
around on the street and everything and
he
interestingly i didn't know this either
he gets discovered
by this guy who um was the director of
like a
radio show that like went all around the
country
so he's like out looking for you know
talented people that are playing music
in the streets of paris
and he gives uh claude a record contract
and claude actually had a kind of a
hit song called honey and cinnamon and
uh like five other singles as well that
did okay
so he was kind of i don't think he was
like super famous or anything like that
but he was like in the charts and
whatnot which is like crazy
so that's in the early i guess it was
like in the late 60s early 70s that was
so after that though like i think the
like the guy that discovered him and was
kind of like his mentor
he ended up committing suicide and that
was in 1970
and then after that claude decides he's
gonna get into his second passion which
was like
race cars so he's like super super into
race cars so what he ended up doing
was he started writing for like um
magazines started racing cars like
around the circuit and whatever
and he started uh this kind of
automotive
racing magazine called auto pop and
started like writing for it so i guess
that started publishing like in 1971.
so that's what he was doing for a couple
of years and then came
1973 late 1973 it was december
so this is how the story goes
and he's written several books if you
want to read them they're all very very
easy to get like on the internet i think
you can even read most of them for free
and they have like a huge website so you
can read most of his stuff
but he wrote this book called the final
message and he talked about
his first contact with the aliens
okay so this happened december 1973 like
i said
so he claimed that he's hiking
around this extinct volcano
right in uh in some part of france now
he kind of hikes around it and then like
he's getting ready to leave like he
turns around and he's going back to his
car
then he turns around to look at the
volcano one last time
and then he sees allegedly
a flashing red light coming down from
the sky
uh he said at first he thought it was a
helicopter
but then um he noticed that the light
wasn't making any noise
and so uh it started coming down like
kind of toward him and he said when it
was about 60 65 feet
above him uh he noticed that it was like
a flying saucer shape you know
yeah uh so he described it as
you know like kind of flattened he said
it was about 23 feet wide
and about eight feet high and he said
that the red light that he had seen at
first was on its
uh on the underside of it and then on
the top there was like a really intense
white light now he said that the saucer
kept coming down
and that when it was about six feet
above the ground
like a door on the underside opened up
and little stairs came out like unfolded
just like your classic
little stairs like 50s little stairs
come out
and then like a little person comes out
so this little person
um he said was about five uh four feet
tall
said he had pale green skin almond
shaped eyes
long dark hair little green man a little
green men
okay yeah he was a little grey man with
long uh black hair which
like like you're dancing with yeah yeah
which maybe you can go to that later and
then you can predict you're not ready
for that you're still doing the french
thing
yeah yeah yeah tila says stairs no beam
i know right it's like it seems like if
they were that because i think that they
said they were 25 000 years ahead in
technology or something and it's like
you'd think that
they'd be over stairs you could just
like unhover
i mean even we have kind of like
rudimentary hoverboards
so you'd think that at least they would
have those so i don't have to like walk
downstairs anymore but whatever
so this alien comes down and introduces
himself do you know
do you know what his name was let me say
let me hold on you think you want to
guess
yeah yeah right pierre
yeah yeah
jean-claude jean-claude pierre
[Laughter]
jean-claude pierre the alien yeah
jean-claude
uh as awesome as that would have been no
yeah okay the alien's name was
yahweh yahweh okay all right i see where
you see where we're going with this god
was an alien all along
yeah that's pretty much the gist of it
okay
so yahweh comes down uh this little
green yahweh
and uh of course he spoke fluent french
uh which is what caused
because well he could speak all
languages because you know aliens yeah
um so then claude says that he follows
the little alien buddy into
the spacecraft uh because yahweh said
hey it's much more comfortable in here
was it i don't know i don't think he
really like described what the inside of
the spaceship looked like unless because
i didn't have time to like read all his
books
but maybe he did describe it maybe it
was like i don't know maybe there's nice
sofas and
you know bean bag chairs or something
like that i don't really know
so they go into they go to the
spacecraft
and the first thing and i love this i
love this so much
because uh this is claude
in his book kind of uh cutting off
all criticisms at the at the root like
before you can get into it
he says that the first thing the alien
said to him other than hey
my name's yahweh i'm an alien obviously
um
was you regret not having brought your
camera
so that you could have talked about our
meeting to the whole world with proof in
your hands
yeah that's the first thing that alien
said i was like oh nice all right that
was a pretty smart thing to do
yeah uh and then claude was like yeah
darn it and claude should have said yeah
you should have met my ass back at the
office
and gone down the [ __ ] news station
with me you're an alien
yeah what i mean really you could do
anything but you know they they always
kind of have like no we have to meet the
secret
i can only i can only show the world my
presence in secret
well they have a he they have a reason
okay all right we have he has a reason
so uh now this is uh apparently a direct
quote from the alien that was from uh
that was from this book that claude
wrote
so yahweh says you will tell human
beings about this meeting
but you will tell them the truth about
what they are and about what about what
we are
judging from their reactions we will
know
if we can show ourselves freely and
officially
wait until you know everything before
you start speaking publicly that might
take a while
i mean to know everything then you will
be able to defend yourself properly
against those people who will not
believe you
and you will be able to bring them
incontestable proof you will write down
everything i tell you and publish the
writings as a book
so basically what the alien is saying is
that
um you like can't tell everybody about
us
until you already know everything about
us and then like the aliens are gonna
gauge
how cool the humans are before
they show themselves to everybody you
got that
yeah that's how that whole thing works
so as i said it's kind of like
that's pretty good covering you covering
your bases
um so apparently
they had that little hang and that was
cool and then
the spaceship was parked there i guess
for the next five days
so claude kept going back every day and
like sitting in the spacecraft with
yahweh
and learning all the stuff like you know
about
the about the history of humans and
about the alien
civilization and whatnot so
at this point yahweh tells him
about the stuff that's in the bible
that's real only it's like
misinterpreted a little bit
so like you said this is a very
prometheus type situation
this is a very cherry to the gods type
situation which i kind of feel like
there was a lot of that kind of stuff
going around yeah he probably read he
probably read
what he probably read that book of the
gods instead of
three yeah when did that come out uh
sixties late sixties i think one did it
uh what was his name um eric mcdanican
again let me go look at them actually i
got people in the comment section
you guys uh find out when chariots of
the gods are yeah when did that come i
kind of thought that was mid 70s but i
could be totally wrong about that
it might have been earlier i think it
was late 60s earlier
i feel like that was something that was
kind of like there was
in the zeitgeist at the time where it
was just kind of like
you know oh all the stuff in the bible
is true except it's aliens and not
that's what they were talking about was
aliens yeah [ __ ] ridley scott had it
right man prometheus would have been
great had they left that [ __ ] script
alone
we read the script yeah that [ __ ]
[ __ ] leaked so it did come out tila
says 1970 victor says 1978 chariots of
the gods so
um so you're 78 no 70 or 68 rather
so either way it's it was before yeah
yeah
so either way uh phil is like jen what
is your first question you would ask an
alien ooh
what would i ask an alien [ __ ]
can you teach me how to teleport i want
to do teleportation
i'm still that's the thing that i'm most
disappointed
um that they haven't invented from star
trek because [ __ ] that would be [ __ ]
that would be so awesome
i would love to because you wouldn't
have to commute anymore you could just
be like boop boop and then you're like
somewhere else
yeah that'd be rad i saw the details
behind i wouldn't have to drive anywhere
that'd be that'd be so [ __ ] sweet i
saw the details behind the technology
they're talking about though
what that would actually do
wouldn't be so much you would be
teleported you'd be disassembled
okay yeah and then reassembled yeah but
here's the thing
there's no difference between
you know disassembling you and
reassembling you than just assembling
you
so what you could do is you could scan
that person and
and know where all the molecules go and
then just
using raw materials record all that as a
program
and instead of teleporting one person
turn that person into two
so you'd have two well which is
essentially what david bowie as
nikola tesla was doing right the
prestige
right and and he invented a machine that
it could teleport you but it actually
cloned you
right so then the way egg heads take
because you know never trust an
intellectual they would say
well wait a minute if if that
if that's all it is why don't we just
disintegrate this person
okay we'll take this person's readings
disintegrate him
and then re make him reappear over there
it's the same person
it's not the same person though that's
still killing you well like i said
that's see the prestige that had that
exact plot point
right that had that exact clock that's
why they talked about it it's because
those eggheads that were talking about
that technology were saying well you
know what
transporting it doesn't really make a
difference that doesn't why not just
scan the person transmit the data to the
remote
place you know what i mean the program
and then just re make a copy over there
yeah like what you did in that in that
program
yeah that would not be you though that's
well yeah well
like i said that's why that was a plot
point in that movie yeah it's like which
sorry i just spoiled it for yeah but it
was i mean the book came out a long time
ago and the movie came out a long time
ago
and you haven't seen the prestige come
on that was like [ __ ] amazing yeah
but yeah dave
did you see that david bowie played
nicholas tesla at it
i mean he was kind of like he wasn't
like the main character it was like two
rival magicians it was christian bale
and uh the dude that played wolverine
what's that [ __ ]
little fucker's name i can't i heard
it's good though it is it's excellent
yeah the book is good too although the
movie is kind of different
but i liked both but i liked him for
different reasons i love that movie
actually there was
it's weird because there was another
movie that came out the same year i
think was called the illusionist and i
was like what's with all the magician
movies not that i'm complaining because
i kind of like like this old
timey like victorian magician type [ __ ]
like just like i like that victorian
spiritualism
seancey type [ __ ] if you make anything
about that i'll watch it seriously
if i had some technology like that y'all
be [ __ ] because i'd make
billions and billions of copies of
myself
tom servo did that on one msg sketch he
just like cloned himself a bunch of
times
yeah i'd make [ __ ] huge army is one
of my favorite skits
that's what and well it made me laugh
because because servo did it and then
like
uh the first thing chris says to him is
like once again you didn't
think things through it's like like
you're so cool we need more of you
i just unleash them you know just say
be fruitful and multiply and then i'd be
your daddies i'd be all your [ __ ]
daddies
that's right everybody would be i'd be
everybody would be my
child that would just genetically
impregnate the earth
i just like the thing like the thing
like
so pro tip just don't give tom control
of anything any technology just
wait that [ __ ] just because i think it
was hilarious
well you would think nobody else would
think it was no is it mine though
no because you the sardonic element in
me would come out that [ __ ] you know
where tom is a legit super villain
like i said that's that's why you
shouldn't like give him anything ever
just don't let him do it give me a
little bitty thing and i'll learn how to
[ __ ] put that in a crack and make
that crack bigger and bigger than just
me popping out yeah
gotcha by the way thank you zach
the trailer for ridley scott's new movie
dropped it's about the assassination of
the head of gucci in the 80s i remember
that
by his ex and she's played by lady gaga
oh that might be
something that might be good really
scott
[Laughter]
you need to keep him away from movies
now
got sidetracked by a neighbor what did i
miss uh tom wants to see the earth with
his clones
yeah that's what you missed they weren't
really clones or copies from a tr
teleporter yeah well essentially they're
all yeah
tom's a legend in his own mind yeah
well that's a reality that did not
happen it's just one that i thought of
one that i proposed
i reject your proposal
[Laughter]
all right so um well you know why i
would do that though
because if that takes cuz you're the
worst no if that technology existed
somebody else would do it so i'd have to
do it first
i'm gonna cut that [ __ ] out i gotta cut
it off right now
well i did it no one else could do it
now well no cause if i don't do it and
somebody else will and i'm gonna let
that happen to me
that's pretty i look at it that way
that's pretty sound blood that's how i
look at it
yeah i look at everything like that
well if i don't do it somebody else will
better me than now goodness gracious
yeah
i'm just saying um yeah so where was i
okay so different kind of logic all
right so
claude who at this point is still called
claude he hasn't had his name changed
yet
so he's having his little uh you know
little classes or whatever with uh with
uh
pierre the alien yahweh rather on the
spaceship
um so yahweh tells him
that uh humans
had been created in laboratories yeah by
aliens okay um you know they were all
genetic geniuses you know they knew all
about cell biology everything like that
and you're gonna love this the creators
of the humans were called the elohim
the halloween the elohim yeah that's
from the bible yeah
yeah so um yeah so what the alien told
claude allegedly
was that yeah everybody says that in the
bible it means angels or god or whatever
but it actually means
quote those who came from the sky so
again very chariots of the gods all this
kind of stuff
uh very ancient aliens this you can
interpret all those gods
god's on mount olympus all the canaanite
gods
you could interpret all those stories as
extraterrestrials
eric von danigan was correct because
they are that's what they're talking
about
the heavens is space it's not really
that crazy i mean i don't believe it's
true
but it's like it's not really that crazy
a belief to come up with
the ancients didn't know what the nature
of the sky was they thought there were
levels so
there are different levels too it's just
like glass up there we live like in a
different level and that there's the
waters of the sky because it's blue
and then the blue meets the horizon and
then the blue goes up so there must be
water in the sky because
the waters of the sky open up and it
rains you know there's different levels
to the heavens that's why some clouds
are above
other clouds in the heavens and then
there's the [ __ ] stars that are set
upon the [ __ ] fundament of the
[ __ ] sky
it's just a different another way of
looking at it so things come
down from the sky you know they're
coming from you know they thought that
[ __ ]
stars were beings too you know celestial
beings so
you know which like i said if you think
about it in that context from their
point of view not knowing any of the
[ __ ] that we know nowadays it's not
really that crazy i believe no
superhuman beings are super human
entities that come
from the sky aliens
they made us they tell you what to do
they look over you
they watch over you there's a bunch of
them only we're watching jerk off
yeah yeah there's a whole bunch of them
there's a whole family of them they
don't like each other sometimes
some of them have chosen you worship
this one don't worship that one
it's it's it's chariots of the gods
yeah well that's the thing it's really
kind of humans
extrapolating i mean you see this all
throughout history if you study
religions and mythologies and stuff like
that
it's just humans like extrapolating
their [ __ ] onto like something but
the next level up yeah i mean especially
if you look at like the greeks and
romans it's like you know the gods
they're gods but it's like they're still
petty [ __ ] like regular ass people oh
yeah man zeus fooling around on his wife
yeah so it's like they do the same [ __ ]
that it's like but but they're all
powerful constantly knocking up mortal
women because they're just [ __ ] hot
and then there's children look i'm a
shower of gold yeah and then god has a
son
with the mortal woman it all sounds
familiar right hercules you know
his mom was immortal and then [ __ ] they
got kinky back in the days
zeus sometimes when he really wanted to
[ __ ] just throw down on immortal
and make sure his wife hera didn't see
it he would disguise himself he would
take
the form of a bull and [ __ ] the woman so
so the god was in the bestiality ouch
yeah they were into some bestiality [ __ ]
there really did seem to be a lot of
that going on back yeah i guess maybe
it's because
um you know i guess the ancients lived
in a lot closer proximity to
animals than most people do nowadays
yeah and they bred animals so you know
then they all had sex
so it was kind of like i guess it wasn't
like that weird that wasn't that weird
hey that bulls looking pretty good well
there was some kind of like
um there was a lot of rumors you know
the main [ __ ]
a lot of ancients from the greek area
you know were always
afraid that their women were having sex
with the bulls
which is kind of like you know the
ultimate cuck porn type idea
that these that these bulls are bigger
than us and they got bigger dicks
for all we know these women like these
bulls more than us
and they're just lying they probably did
in some cases
that they're not having sex with these
bulls like at least the bulls don't talk
and then like then you can go well what
if that bull was actually
zeus you couldn't kill the bull see yeah
disrespectful yeah you know
it's all kind of so they lived in a
different world man
i don't i don't think educated people
believed any of that
no i don't think so um i mean i've read
[ __ ] from that time period from
like i said like more educated people
and that sounded like pretty modern
yeah well romans straight out right that
[ __ ] ed
that religion was for
poor people the plebes yeah um they had
an imperial cult
and they did worship the imperial gods
but it was mostly a tradition thing
and to give um uh confidence
to the to the people that the god that
that the correct gods were being
worshipped even though they themselves
didn't believe in them
yeah in other words they went through
the motions to look
traditional and to look you know
legendary and
conservative and proper but but the rich
people didn't believe any of that yeah
it was all like it was all like a
performance yeah as a performance art
yeah mark says just made it can you
start over
yeah yeah we're gonna start
you missed all the stuff about all tom's
clones taking over the earth
impregnating the earth someone we need
to make that movie
yeah i could probably do it like a
horror movie action movie slash porn
movie
yeah i just need like i just need a
whole bunch of
footage of you just like running around
and then i'll just
like you know i'll photoshop it like
over the whole entire earth all these
little times
he says my husband is a taurus i can
relate okay
[Laughter]
oh my goodness we're all we're all
getting yeah we're [ __ ] she's saying
that zeus is her heavy pet name her new
pet name for the hubby
yeah rare hit it zeus
[Laughter]
does he come by here anymore i haven't
seen him in a long time who
tila's husband no i haven't seen him in
a while yeah t get on your other
other account and impersonate your
husband
come on that'll be super funny no i'm
just kidding um t's actually a white
dude
aren't we all white dudes deep down but
um
fourth jar down said nobody mentions
that the nazca lines could have been
made by anyone with a stick and a piece
of string
true uh yeah she says she's gonna get
that
husband yeah get the hubby to come by
when he gets home all right hi pokey
yeah the nazca lines are not as
impressive as people think they are
what are you doing things about the
nazca lines cause those are processional
lines you walked across
you walked around there they were
walking
this it was something that you walked
through like a path during
certain ceremonial rituals phil says did
anybody ever read the book the white
hotel that starts out very dirty it goes
into flying uteruses ooh i like it
and bull drizzle damn all right i like
it
yeah you go the story of the minotaur is
kind of beasty it kind of be beastie yes
well there was
women and children to the minotaur
what's exactly is he doing to them
they're saying i think it says it
ravished women minotaur stuff
yeah well there's a man that is a whole
subgenre of porn
yeah is like man beast combos
whoa like that's i think that's one of
the best selling sub genres actually if
i'm not mistaken well okay i'm gonna
tell you guys a story this is um
back i think it was in the 1700s
i think it was 1700s or 1600's they were
uncovering this [ __ ]
uh roman statue it was this beautiful
quality
and all these [ __ ] real proper
[ __ ]
aristocrats were sitting there watching
them uncover this thing and had all the
ladies there they're all dressed in
their finery
and it turns out to be a very [ __ ]
famous statue
of a seder which is a boy with horns or
a man with
horns goat horns and goat legs it's a
seder
raping a female goat yeah and it's a
very famous standard it's a nice statue
beautiful quality ancient roman statue
and they see that thing and they were
just oh
they were just oh wow vandalized they
covered it up
that's my favorite
yeah the vatican took it and they go we
gotta hide this they [ __ ] hid that
[ __ ] down in the damn basement
because they didn't have any of the
contacts they came from an old roman
story but they were into that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
centaurs and women and um
well centaurs in particular were really
known for uh
being might reap putting a big horse
dick down on the girl
just it was softly putting it
i kind of think these were all kind of
[ __ ] mechanisms to [ __ ] cuck out
dudes
man imagine that dude you know i think
you know i think that's what it is
yeah it's to knock you off your high
horse man they got a [ __ ] who is
a horse running around
trying to put the dick on your wings and
he's just gonna like slap you in the
face with that big old dad
i don't know what they were thinking man
they were just but it was probably
something it was probably something
along those lines something along those
lines probably yeah
uh red m10 says yeah the minotaur is the
result of the queen of crete
laying with a bull yeah she asked for a
special device to be made to help
oh okay yeah oh she specifically can you
like make some things so we can yeah wow
that's like that's on a whole other
level of hoery right there yeah
i mean you're just like wanting a
special thing
yeah what happened pokey
she's begging okay what do you want you
don't want anything
she's always she's kind of like i kind
of want to go outside but then like when
you open the door she's like no i don't
want to go outside and then she just
goes in and then she comes back and her
little back arches up but she forgets
that it's hot
yeah she forgets she gets well because
it's nice and cool in here so it's like
oh here we go here we go yeah
here it is yeah look at daddy poke it
ready to see them statues
you're ready to see the statues okay
okay
all right so uh so yeah so at this point
where where was i in the story so he
uh tells them about the elohim or
whatever yeah
and that they were actually aliens uh at
this point
uh yahweh or pierre the alien as we'll
call him from now on
um gave claude his new name which was
rile like i said with the
umlaut because it's he's metal and uh
told him
i want you to spread the message of how
humans were created
also he very specifically wanted an
embassy built um
for when the elohim were coming to the
earth
uh because apparently the elohim wanted
to come to earth and meet with all the
world leaders just like in all the 50
sci-fi movies
and share their advanced technology
with us but uh
there was a condition in that the elohim
didn't want to come here
until world peace had been achieved good
luck with that
um so they're never coming and
good luck with that man that's what i'm
saying
that's not gonna happen and the embassy
had been built and they wanted it built
in jerusalem they didn't i don't know if
they gave specifications over what they
wanted or did they want a hot tub
how many bathrooms 70 bedrooms i don't
know but apparently
uh yeah they wanted a uh an embassy when
that's done
and when there's world peace then the
aliens will come to earth and hang with
us and give us all their advanced
technology like i said that's a pretty
good way of like pushing [ __ ] off to
essentially
never because yeah that's never gonna
happen
uh so at this point uh rael is like okay
can do and he pretty much
thank you david hail pookie look pookie
somebody's like worshipping you she's
like that's okay i'm just sniffing stuff
on the carpet i don't care
she goes around on the carpet and goes
like it's actually smelling stuff but it
sounds like she's like snuffling out i'm
not really sure what that is
but uh yeah so rael starts a movement
i don't know i feel like there's not a
lot known because i feel like everything
that i read about this
is just kind of like yeah the aliens
came and talked to him for six days or
whatever
and they told him hey like you need to
build an embassy and you need to start
this movement tell everybody that
aliens made us and we're gonna come here
when everybody gets their [ __ ] together
and then he starts out and then suddenly
he has like a few hundred followers
and then it just like keeps building up
and up i guess i don't
i don't know i was i'm always fascinated
by
the early days of the cult because you
know how hard it is to like start
you know like a small business or
something like that for example
and how hard it is to get the word out
and how i said and yet
some dude in france who's just like some
random dude that was just like a street
musician or
and wrote for race car magazine he comes
out
and says um an alien landed and talked
to me
for a week and told me all this stuff
and so let's start a movement and
everyone's like okay
you know what i mean the fact that you
would get
people to go along with that is like
that blows my mind that blows my mind
maybe i just haven't tried hard enough i
don't really know
i always kind of feel like maybe i can
come up with some really stupid story
and get like a bunch of people
like to like follow along i don't know
but like i said this really doesn't seem
i'm not sure the dude okay so vice
did a document where a guy did a
documentary for vice
um that's called what's it called i
think it's called the prophet in the
space aliens
and he basically went and hung out with
um with ryle and the
and them and his followers
and i watched like some of it but then
after a while i kind of got bored and i
wandered off and did some other stuff
but
because it was mostly kind of like hey
look at all these you know happy ass
people and it was i don't know it just
wasn't all that
exciting so um so i didn't watch the
whole thing but
it did seem like the only thing that
made me suspicious
was that right at the beginning of the
documentary
like when the dude i can't remember the
name of the dude that made it
but um he was filming
them and he and ryle and the this other
woman
i don't remember if it was his wife or
just one of his followers but they were
walking a little bit ahead of the
documentary filmmakers and ralph said
just remember you're being recorded so
watch what you say or something like
that
so that was the only thing that kind of
made me suspicious
you know what i'm saying so i'm kind of
like maybe he wanted this documentary as
kind of like
to make him look good and stuff and
maybe there is nefarious [ __ ] going on
but even the people that have left
um the the religion or left the cult or
whatever
don't really seem to have anything that
you know nothing like you know
scientology where it's like you know
people were like [ __ ] beaten up and
you know put in put in trailer like
locked in trailers for years at a time
or anything like that
there i haven't really heard anything
about that
but the fact that he said that is a
little bit weird but
you know i don't know so
demo look pretty with this
i do kind of love it uh yeah mark said
how do you think dudes get laid half of
it's being a good storyteller
yeah oh yeah i guess that's yeah i guess
that's what it is
they will never let you into space if
you're married to a stripper well i
don't know about that
and then tila said i feel like aliens
would be most interested in strippers
you'd think
i mean everybody loves strippers right
aliens wouldn't give a [ __ ] about any of
our technology or anything
probably probably or any of our
so-called natural resources
everything that the earth is made out of
is common including water and everything
that's just [ __ ] everywhere on the
kuiper belt there's [ __ ] huge
planetoids full of water
frozen ice which is the only thing that
they would ever be interested in us
would be people that might make them
interested
in artwork human artwork
either that or just people because we're
delicious maybe they just want to eat us
like maybe we're like a delicacy
chances are most aliens are not
biological
i would imagine they're probably living
machines
i don't need to eat
yeah random tenant says i mean the
elohim in this story definitely love
strippers
i do kind of feel like they do because
there's a lot of uh there's a lot
there's a lot of sex stuff going on in
the skull
but that but it's all it all seems to be
um
consenting sex stuff so i don't really
have a problem with it like i said i
don't it's there
i haven't really heard anything about
like weird underage [ __ ] or
anything crazy like that in other words
just like a club scene
yeah it's kind of it kind of strikes me
more as like a hippie commune
everybody's happy type of [ __ ] rather
than
i mean you know see this [ __ ] love it
on this one
[Laughter]
you need like a bell yeah it's the
ultimate [ __ ] prettiness
i don't know why you don't like you
should have worn one of your jackets
when white boys were white boys when
they were wigs and tails were wigs and
tights and high heels yes
yeah little [ __ ] knee socks and [ __ ]
i know i love it checking out who had
the best calves
yeah see that needs to come back i feel
like
that was pretty that was some pretty
slick looking [ __ ]
[ __ ] knew how to dress back
then they looked all [ __ ] tired i
don't
i i got i have a feeling most most dudes
didn't wear that
only only real rich guys wore this well
yeah that was kind of like an upper
class that's so [ __ ] rich people
everybody else just wore like regular
[ __ ] yeah baggy work pants and [ __ ] like
that
so yeah so he started uh you know the
the raelian
movement because of course he named it
after himself that's not his real name
but you know that was
yeah real white boy right there
thank you tom that's right that's right
you'd buy a wig for your old man put
that on him
that way you accomplished something
that's a real white man like on the
money
like on the money yeah that's [ __ ]
funny
now uh okay so so he starts the movement
and then uh a couple years later
apparently according to
another one of his books because he's
like i said he's written a [ __ ] ton of
books about
all of his experiences and what the
aliens told him and stuff
um so it's 1975
and then apparently yahweh or pierre the
alien
as we're calling him comes back to earth
this time i guess he wants to see his
old buddy wanted to see his old buddy
rael so he comes back in the saucer like
dropped by
rile's house it's like hey bro long time
no see i don't know if that's what
happened i'm just like you know making
it up
uh so they pick him up and they take him
out into the galaxy somewhere
um outside of the solar system
apparently
they go to an orbiting spa which sounds
nice
uh he got some aromatherapy treatment a
nice massage
some [ __ ] like that maybe maybe a mud
bath maybe a facial i don't know making
stuff up at this point
uh although the aromatherapy and the
massage is true that was in the book
he went out to a spot i don't know i
can't prove it's not there i'm just
saying
maybe there's a spot out there in space
i don't know uh
so then apparently they go to
the uh the homeworld of the elohim
uh which was like a jungle planet and
it's called the planet of the eternals
because you know you'd think they'd come
up with a better name than that thank
you zack
the cult had a jewish influence right
sorta yeah i don't hear much about
extremism or crazy people when it comes
to judaism half the nicest people i ever
met jewish for whatever reason yeah
yeah i think it's because they don't
really have a tradition of
um trying to like convert people
uh maybe that's what it is they don't
really seem all that
because this one seems it is kind of
jewish influenced a little bit i guess
but this one is kind of like
they have a thing where it's pretty much
all religions
have some correct to them because
their whole argument is you know the
aliens created everybody
but every culture had a different
interpretation
of the aliens you know and how it's so
that's why
the religions are a little bit different
so he's kind of like covering all the
bases
so in that way they're actually really
open-minded
to pretty much all religions and what
that vice documentary i was watching one
of the things that a lot of
um particularly their african members
like about it
is that um rael apparently tells them
that they should
like stay with their own like they're
you know they're they're more like
traditional beliefs
like african beliefs rather than you
know the colonialist
type of stuff being for you know what i
mean they should go back to their like
traditions and stuff
what what um zach is talking about is
judaism is not
evangelical yeah that's what i said i'm
trying to like convert anybody
islam and christianity are evangelical
they like to spread you know they have
different ways to do it
judaism is more about have to have to do
with ethnicity
come here what are you doing who's
related to who yeah basically if you're
born of a jewish mother you're jewish
yeah so while um
rael is on the planet of the eternals
which like i said they need a snappier
name
for the planet i mean you'd think it
would be better than i don't know planet
of the eternals
so uh while he's there he gets to meet
uh jesus and buddha muhammad moses
all of them were there everybody's
hanging out on the planet they all went
out for dinner
probably had some beers i don't know
watch the game i don't know
again the dinner part's true so
then uh ryle goes to uh
this lab which is where
they're making the people which
are like biological robot type things
so apparently while he was there they
made
a biological robot of his mom
and then also they made a bunch of
you know hot young women because of
course they did yeah
and then they all go and party i don't
know if rl's mom was also involved in
the party slash
orgy which i'm imagining uh which would
be a little weird but i guess it's not
his real mom
so i guess it's weird but okay
whatever um and apparently in one of his
books he has written extensively about
what happened at this party so i'm sure
that's like a really
entertaining read [ __ ] man i should have
like downloaded the ebook and we could
have like write it on here tell them
what happened it's been like super funny
because well i'm sure i'm sure it
probably was
because like i said there's a lot of
there's a lot of sex going on in this
religion um but as it seems to be all
consensual
uh i'm not really bothered yeah yeah i'm
not mad about it
uh yeah so but yeah please go read this
dude's books there i'm sure that they're
really easy to get i think a lot of them
are even free
um because he's written a [ __ ] ton of
them and it's funny i'm sure they're
wildly entertaining
what's funny about people's reactions to
religions like this where religions that
mix sex
in western culture middle eastern too
the idea of
mixing sex and religion is like [ __ ]
oh my god it's horrible
but if you look throughout histories
most of them were like that yeah i mean
that's a pretty recent
yeah that's a recent innovation isn't
the word that i thought that was
abrahamic religions and conor were
against that
most other religions weren't against it
at all they even had temple prostitution
and stuff
yeah where a temple was a whorehouse it
was like a holy whorehouse
but we're not raised well they did that
too in christianity or that christian
cult what was that called the [ __ ]
uh children of god yeah with the flirty
fishing which is pimping out your
[ __ ] women
you know they do it too you can justify
anything in any way you want to if you
put the right spin on the scripture
you know yeah as long as people like
people believe it if you got a good
story you got a good story they'll spin
it
but uh no sex and
alcohol or sex drugs and entertainment
and spectacle
were usually the driving force that kept
a religion alive
in in um in in civilization
rome especially they didn't have
nightclubs they had temples
you paid to get in and they even had a
coin operating machine
sometimes it would dispense things like
wine they had drugs in it
you'd watch something they put a band
around your wrist not really
spectacle of moving statues and dancing
and weird stories that they're telling
his eyes bleed
yeah and then uh getting loaded and
drinking and
having sex you know worshiping bacchus
or something which is the god of [ __ ]
wine
and and having holy revelations through
all this
drug taking man revelations last night
they're like let's do that again next
week
let's do that again next weekend yeah i
had some revelations before too like the
next morning
that's exactly what it was it was big
business it was part of the
entertainment industry they didn't have
movies or anything or tv
so it was it was all wrapped up into one
thing
christianity was like that too it was
just not as fun
yeah they didn't have they didn't have
that seems like
i don't know it's it's amazing to me
that they actually got
that many people to like go along with
it because it seemed like they had all
the party religions like before that and
then like christians came along and said
let's not have any of that blah blah
blah and everyone's like
well christianity did not contrary to
what
modern christians were are taught to
believe
christianity did not spread like
wildfire
word of mouth no it took a loss actually
it happened in one
fell swoop and that was rome made it
the government back religion if you
wanted to get
promoted you had to be a christian and
that was what two i think it was around
uh
since second century third century i
think the uh
i want to say it was 300 something yeah
three separate i can't remember
it became the official religion and uh
eventually they started outlawing other
ones but it took a long time
you know yeah so it was kind of just
it was put in there by government power
government decree
so everyone at least had to pay lip
service to it yeah you know even if they
didn't really believe it and they were
still going to partying with the bacchus
people
which is totally eventually all all
competitors were eliminated
like what's the religion that's going to
like make me let me drink and do
whatever i want right
okay i'm going to go with that one well
you know our concept of
the abrahamic concept of what a religion
is is
only in abrahamic religions only then do
you need a barrett
buddhism buddhism isn't isn't like that
the ancient religions were not like that
ancient egyptian religion may have been
a little bit like that may have been a
little bit like christianity probably
like catholicism
yeah um seems to be based on what people
have said about it amanda marie asked if
we had watched the borgias we haven't
yet
but um i that is on my list i do want to
actually watch that
um yeah so ryle at this point like i
said he met jesus and buddha and moses
and all them
and uh he's still on the planet of the
eternals
and then he gets taken to this other
place
where they put this helmet thing on him
and this helmet is supposed to
like juice up his brain or something
like put all the smarts in there
it's putting all the smart into his
brain because
because he's gonna be like um an
ambassador
of the aliens he has to be like one of
the smartest [ __ ] on earth
right so they have to like cram all this
stuff into his brain with the helmet
because as i mentioned before one thing
that uh raelians believe is that
the world should be run by geniuses a
geniocracy
geniocracy yeah like only the smartest
people should run [ __ ]
also though well no i know but um
also they don't think that they think
that you should have to pass an iq test
to vote
um other things like that yeah um
but yeah they think that only that
geniuses should should be the ones
running the earth
yeah they ripped that off in the early
1900s there was a political
party in the united states called the
the technocrats you can look them up
thank you phil the technocrats believed
that too they wanted
they wanted a technocracy which is a
government run by
professionals because of course they're
honest yeah
you know and educated people um they
were the
prototype of american communists really
what they were
but they were little gray uniforms and
like something out of damn metropolis
the movie metropolis from the 20s that's
exactly what they look like
um but they i guess they they vanished
over time i think they probably got
absorbed by
communist and socialist parties of the
early 1900s
now i will note that the raelians they
did say that they thought the earth
should be run by geniuses but they
didn't necessarily think that that meant
people that had just like studied a lot
or you know
that didn't necessarily mean people with
a lot of degrees because they did say
like there were some working-class
people that were smarter than people
that just like
so it was just like yeah so it was just
that type of thing that actually might
work
which like i said i don't know though
because like iq tests they'd have to be
redesigned because they're very
uh they only really test like one very
narrow yeah just problem solving
that's pretty much all they test some
puzzles
and that's not necessarily because i've
known people that were
didn't do good on tests or didn't do
good on iq tests but they were like
really smart in other ways
so not everyone is smart in that very
one narrow like particular way
i actually read that they have changed a
lot of that though they probably have at
this point because so many people have
complained about it because people were
complaining about that like back in the
70s
well they said there was a different
kinds of genius you had mathematical
genius and then you had uh other kinds
of [ __ ] spatial genius
people that could [ __ ] see distances
and see
shapes the way other people couldn't see
it and another one that kind of
[ __ ] weighed me out with something
called genius of social engineering
which is a person who is a genius at
manipulating people
yeah which that's what would have
nothing to do
with those iq tests and they said that
what
indicated a person's ability to succeed
in a mass
power was how well they scored upon that
[ __ ]
yeah on on that [ __ ] social genius
what they call it human engineering
genius yeah
that those guys actually rose to the top
because they're just manipulative
they know they can predict the reactions
of others and
set a stage to get people to do things
for them that they're actually the ones
that are
has nothing to do with mathematical
genius you know what i mean
in other words yeah those are two
completely different right yeah yeah
some of these real intelligent guys
never really make much out of their
lives because it's too narrow
and then some of the guys that can
become [ __ ] great leaders and [ __ ]
billionaires and trillionaires they're
just really manipulative
yeah you know what i mean and they don't
test for that
but they need to they probably should i
mean i kind of feel like the only
the only way they test for that is when
they're doing tests if you're like a
sociopath right
they're all high functioning psychopaths
yeah that's kind of spooky but they have
the advantage because they don't care
well yeah by any means well yeah that's
what i mean it's
you know having a conscience everybody
should have a conscience but in some
ways uh having one can be kind of a
handicap
i think they do have a conscious it's
just that they they don't have a problem
with things that you would have problems
in other words they're like no i'm
[ __ ] this person over because they're
weak
well yeah they have yeah like i said i'm
supposed to do this yeah this is the way
it's supposed to be
yeah you know might makes right i'm
better than this person so i'm just
going to take their [ __ ]
you know and uh it might be
he's smarter [ __ ] has more power he's
amassed more he's actually playing the
game
in a war-like way he's planned this out
and
in a way he's winning because he's made
himself a winner
and he's like well you know mike makes
right i'm gonna do this because
to put to leave you in charge would be
wrong i'm going to be in charge
it's that kind of thinking yeah yeah
i get that but like i said it's you know
some of us some of them
of course they're at their assets but
you you can't amass power and not be an
[ __ ]
it's very very difficult i mean i'm sure
yeah watch the news
well that's what i mean it can be done
but it's really really
real real hard because you have to crush
a lot of other [ __ ] on your way up
you do yeah yeah you do uh yeah it's a
in that way like nice guys do finish
last i gotta say
uh not not so much in you know just
regular life but if you're
trying to like be rich and famous or
anything like that hey that that [ __ ]
being nice is not that serious spartacus
right out
that siri spartacus was at least [ __ ]
honest about that [ __ ]
although you do they did eventually get
theirs because what goes around comes
around that was the game they were
playing well see that's another thing
is that there's always somebody that's
going to he's a bigger fish with bigger
fish than yeah
that's going to kick your ass yeah you
know you do that to people
you [ __ ] people over because somebody's
bigger than you is going to come along
and [ __ ] you over just
harder yep you know but that was the
crucible they were being
that's what i mean it's like so you have
to accept that like don't whine about it
because that's right you do not have the
right to hand
death out to others when you're gonna
cry like a [ __ ] when somebody hands it
out to you
it's it's equal opportunity it's a
hater's game but it's equal opportunity
equal opportunity hate in a way i think
that's what makes me mad
about because you know we talk about a
lot of like shitty people on this show
yeah you know like a lot of murderers
and stuff like that i think it makes me
even it makes me hate them
even more when when their time when
their time comes and then they start
crying about it and it's like i'm trying
to come up with some excuse i'm like
[ __ ]
at least give people you know
at least have the [ __ ] self-respect
to come out
like a [ __ ] man yeah i did that [ __ ]
you got me right
you know i'm not saying that makes what
they did better but i'm just saying
that don't like do all that [ __ ] and was
like yeah i can do what i want but like
when you get caught like
oh suddenly you're crying and oh but my
i'm a victim remember
there were a few cases we haven't talked
about them yet but i remember hearing
them we had this one guy
where he was he was in his 20s he was
just hell-bent on
raping little boys and hanging him and
killing him when he was done i think he
did two or three of them he
i think he did one of them in an
abandoned house and hung the boy in a
[ __ ] closet oh i know you're talking
about that but i can't think of his name
when they caught him uh they wanted to
try to get him life he goes no no no i
want death
and they were like what and he goes i
don't deserve to live and he said
and there's well at least he was that
self-aware and he says and then he said
and he said
and i can never be free because i'll
just do it again he says i'll do it
again
see like i said those are still horrible
people but at least
but at least they were self-aware and
they fessed up and they didn't try to
come up with some excuse
yeah or try to wiggle their way out of
it yeah so at least again yeah
just don't let me go because i can't
stop myself
he told the court he was a monster and
that he needed to die
and that he couldn't be released at
which point they should just take him
out back and just like shoot him in the
head he says if you release me i'll do
it
he said if you release me i'll do it
again because that's what i do
you know so you you have to kill me
that's my thing yeah it was his thing
that was his sexual orientation
yeah so you know you know
and i'm not saying like i said i don't
think any of them are worthy of respect
i'm just saying that
but at least he was honest at least yeah
that much
you had like one tiny little modicum one
little iota
yeah a [ __ ] it was also still kind of
self-serving he wanted to spend the rest
of his life in prison well that too
but at least he went headlong into death
i mean he was killing little boys you
[ __ ] need to [ __ ] go headlong into
death [ __ ]
amanda marie said i know you never
covered this case but the dating game
killer rodney alcala died in prison i
don't know if anyone knew
yeah i've been wanting to do that case
for a long time actually because that
dude like [ __ ] creep me out he was on
the [ __ ] dating game and everything i
put it in the poll a bunch of times but
it never wins
uh we'll probably get around to it maybe
we should do it
soon then because if he just died um
so you know because yeah i don't want to
do that for a while
i can't remember i i don't remember as
much about his crimes as i do about that
[ __ ]
creepy [ __ ] about him being on the
dating game so
all right so where are we i don't know
okay
so 1975
um he apparently comes back ryle
apparently comes back from his
um 666 day
vacation in the galaxy where he went to
the spa and he met jesus and everything
so you know that was fun um so when he
comes back to earth like i said at this
point um
he has like a few hundred followers
and then over the ensuing decades um
he's got like a pretty respectable
you know as religions go i guess like as
small religions go he's got a pretty
respectable following
uh their website their official website
i think says 40 000
which maybe maybe that's an exaggeration
uh some other sociologists that have
looked into it
said maybe it's more like twenty
thousand but could be thirty thousand so
it's not
that far off um many of them
i think like the vast majority of them
are in uh europe and mainly france
uh japan has a [ __ ] ton of them about
four thousand five thousand people there
and four or five thousand in quebec also
those are kind of like there's some
there's a bunch in south korea as well
for some reason in japan and south korea
it's kind of like
it's not a big thing it's only like a
few thousand people but they do have
like a lot of i think after europe
that's like their biggest
um area of people being in it
uh so yeah but i think it's like 67 68
countries
they have members in uh and they also
say that their
numbers are growing i don't know if
that's true or not because
scientologists say that too and that's
obviously not true no they've been their
numbers have been growing
by their numbers [ __ ] the whole
continent is scientologist that [ __ ]
[ __ ] we'll see scientologists count
every time we handed a pamphlet to
somebody but they're now a scientologist
i kind of feel like they count that
they're so they're fudging the numbers
just a tad
scientologists are full of [ __ ] well i
kind of like all religions are full of
[ __ ]
i mean i'm just gonna say that right now
um so
i'm not like i said i'm not lumping
these people in with scientologists
because these people even though it's
kind of a similar belief system as
you know vis-a-vis aliens yeah but
these people seem a lot less uh like i
said a lot less nefarious
than the scientologists do for sure
another one that's full of [ __ ] that a
lot of
christians get pissed when they look at
those numbers of how many muslims are
alive
you know what i mean oh my god they're
outnumbering us that that number is
[ __ ] too
because those islamic countries count
every one of their citizens as islamic
whether they believe that [ __ ] or not
because there's a lot of crypto
non-believers or just
what they call cultural muslims where
they're
graced in a muslim society they're not
real religious and i kind of feel like
that happens in a lot of christian
countries too where a lot of people are
like cultural you know
i go to church on like christmas and
easter but they don't give a [ __ ] about
it the rest of the time what
that's what they're doing and and it
would be
what what what what islam what what the
islamic churches do
is they basically count everybody well
that'd be like a christian church here
count everybody in europe and in the
united states as a christian
that's probably probably some of them
trying to probably try to do that i
think i feel like they do try to do that
yeah and i'm like hey i'm not i'm not in
that
can i just say for a long for a while
you know when i was living in egypt
i was under under the impression that
islam was the same everywhere
now it's like it's like christianity
it's there's a bunch of major
denominations then a bunch of tiny bunch
of other ones and it also depends on
where you
where you grew up in islam a lot of a
lot of those islamic people are not
religious
well yeah like i said it's just like
christianity it's just because some
people say yeah
you know if you act if somebody asked
you outright like what religion you are
like you were raised that and you still
kind of believe it maybe yeah but you
don't really think about it in your
day-to-day life
no they'll look at isis and go that's
not that's not islam that's
that's [ __ ] that's not islam and
that would be the same as a christian
seeing some like
real [ __ ] hardcore christian
fundamentalist [ __ ] you know
shooting a place up you know like an
abortion
yeah and they say well that's not a
christian
the thing is
yeah so i was gonna say the thing is
though is that it's all man-made
interpretations
yeah anybody can interpret anything as
anything
is is is isis real islam yeah
it is they're following that [ __ ]
literally but it's the average
islamic person doing that no the average
islamic person is kind of like the
average christian
christian person they have christmas you
know right
yeah it's like every now and then
they're like whoo and they're all like
cultural christmas but then the rest of
the time like i said they don't think
about it
they just think about regular life [ __ ]
like exactly they're just living their
normal life they're not real religious
they have
[ __ ] cultural uh mores that they do
they're not that different from a
westerner really
um you know when i was [ __ ] having
fun with them
in in egypt you know and also in the
sinai peninsula down dahab and stuff
partying with them you know uh out there
in dahab and uh
had one guy you know they were playing
this [ __ ] house song in the head
what was the one where you had arnold
schwarzenegger going hasta la vista baby
remember that old [ __ ]
uh uh techno song yeah the arab dude
next to me was in egyptian he goes what
does hasta la vista mean
since you know what that means and let's
just see you later in spanish he was
oh who is that schwarzenegger arnold
schwarzenegger yeah i had to tell him
about terminators
oh the terminator that's the yeah it's
the terminator he knew the terminator
was
i mean and you know but i guess he saw a
dubbed version
um so he didn't realize that that was
what what what you know good
yeah lots of things are like lost and
translated yeah because maybe i guess
the arabic version of
terminator 2 was of course dubbed and
hasta la vista wouldn't translate and
they probably never even heard of
arnold schwarzenegger's voice that's
true isn't that weird to think about
yeah because i feel like in a lot of
countries they do dub the [ __ ] yeah stop
so he didn't get it even though i can't
but god i can't [ __ ] stand dubbing i
really wish they wouldn't do it
i mean the only time it doesn't bother
me is like giallo movies because that's
part of the whole experience but
normally uh you know i'm reading the
subtitles i don't wanna i don't want
like a bunch of people and like not
talking in their real voices it like
wakes me up
yeah tila says an iranian friend of mine
calls practicing muslims in the u.s make
muslims because the women can drive and
women can
date and eat meals together yeah it's
that's kind of the way christianity was
formed you know what i mean when you had
um people people from jewish backgrounds
living in the roman empire
over time they became so roman that they
had to reboot their religion into
christianity
it was a reason they were
they were they were kind of like the
mick jews of the roman
uh that's another good band name jews
the big jews they were like to make jews
they kind of have to be scottish though
to be funny that'd be funnier
they could be like a scottish folk band
right but that could sing like hanukkah
songs
man i've got all kind of good ideas
today yeah
i don't know what it is i've got all
kind of good ideas for bands
that no one's ever gonna form but you
know
uh yeah so uh where was i okay so
that's probably do we have any booze
left yeah okay
i don't have any of that cherry left
though that's okay what do we have left
um i'll make you something okay it'll be
a surprise
i guess all my cherry vodka is gone [ __ ]
which i totally forgot i totally forgot
that i just keep i just take it for
granted because we haven't drank since
wednesday
so i kind of take it for granted that
it's like we still got booze because we
usually have like three or four bottles
uh in there but i just take it for
granted there was him in there and then
10 minutes before the show he's like uh
we don't really have that much booze
left so i guess we just have to drink
whatever
but i said that's okay because i don't
want to get too [ __ ] [ __ ] up
because i'm
super sleepy so yeah so they say that
the movement's growing like i said i
don't know if that's true or not because
you know all religions kind of like
[ __ ] their numbers because they're
always like whoo
we're taking over the world you know
what i mean although like i said i kind
of feel like the
raelians don't they don't seem to want
to take over the world
um not in the sense that
as other religions do where it's like
yeah we want everybody to convert to
this i think because they're pretty cool
with like people being whatever religion
they're just kind of like we just want
everybody to be cool with each other and
acknowledge that
we were all made by aliens and that
unless we're all cool with each other
the aliens aren't going to come here
so we all want to be cool so the aliens
will come here so that's kind of like
their endgame
so which like i said doesn't seem
terribly it's it's loopy but it's not
nefarious
that's it right there that's the last of
it okay thank you it's good
whipped cream and taste it whipped cream
and powder it smells good
oh yeah good tastes like a pineapple
upside down cake
so by 1997 uh the
religion had raised about seven million
dollars
now the seven million dollars is toward
the construction of the embassy
because remember i said how the aliens
said you have to build an embassy in
jerusalem before we'll come there also
there has to be world peace because like
so like i said that'll never happen but
they did have seven million dollars for
the embassy
now so apparently they're going to have
the money for the embassy but
they ran into problems wanting to build
the embassy in jerusalem
one of the problems being uh that the
israeli government did not really like
if you guys have seen the symbol
that the re the raelians use
the symbol that they use i don't know
why they didn't just come up with their
own logo like i said
but the symbol is like a jewish star
with a swastika in the middle
which like i said it seems like
um not much forethought went into that
so as you can imagine the israeli
government
was a little testy about why
like can we can we build an embassy here
oh by the way
here's our symbol and they're like yeah
we don't like that um
so they're kind of having some problems
in that regard
they did actually change their logo i
think in the 90s
to a jewish star but now it just has
like a swirl in the middle that's
supposed to like represent a galaxy or
whatever which to me like makes more
sense
um i don't know why they put they they
keep insisting and i think i've talked
about this on the wednesday show they
keep insisting that
yeah but the swastika just means like
the four wins and it's just kind of
which it does i get that but
not a lot of people know that anymore
like the association's been forever
tainted
uh so it's really not worth it
i feel like to use i mean it's just like
a bunch of lines you could come up with
another series of lines that isn't
offensive to like millions of people
i'm just saying so they did actually
change it but still the israeli
government were like yeah i still don't
know
uh they don't know how they feel about
it so um
so i guess i don't know how it's going
now like i said i think they do have
money to at least kind of get started on
the building
um but israel is still saying like yeah
i don't know if we want that here
so maybe they said well maybe we can
build it in egypt or palestine or
somewhere i don't know they're trying to
like build it someplace because they
want the aliens to come here
but like i said they can build all the
embassies they want
but and there's that whole caveat of
like there has to be world peace before
the aliens come i was just like that's
not you're never gonna achieve that no
one said that they're not gonna come
here
so uh at this point uh also 1997
and this is probably the thing that
they're best known for because this was
all over the [ __ ] media like in the
90s
uh and early 2000s so in 97
um the raelians they said that they had
formed this company called valiant
venture
limited and uh their service they
started a service called
clonade which like i said this kind of
is the main thing that people know about
them
now initially what they wanted to do
they're like we want to develop
a human cloning technology which the
aliens apparently told
uh rael about the first thing they
wanted to do was they wanted to give
infertile couples um you know gay
couples stuff like that
they wanted to give them uh they want to
be able to like clone one of the
partners and like then you can have like
a kid if you can't have a kid so that
was kind of like what their
you know who their audience was i guess
so
so they formed this now on their site
their whole thing is that the aliens
uh because they they created all the
life on earth
using dna so
it's just kind of like
the raelians because of this they're
really one thing i kind of like about
them
is they're very science positive
because because the aliens are so
far ahead technologically um
the raelians are very into
technology and using technology to
improve
people's lives which i think is cool um
because like i said a lot of religions
you kind of see like oh science is the
devil and blahdy blah
so you're it's used to i'm used to being
like an antagonistic relationship
but the raelians are very very
pro-science they're very into
dna like they're into all the cloning
stuff they're in nanotechnology
they're really into uh genetic
engineering of like you know uh
gmos like making bigger crops like to
feed more people
like anything that will make people's
lives better um
they're all about it which in a way i
think is like
cooler than most religions gotta say
you know yeah camp guys in there saying
that they can clone other things why
they probably can't close to humans
cloning is not as high-tech people think
it is it's really not it's kind of done
by hand in a certain way
they do have some new tools now where
they're shooting pieces of
dna strands into cells of or
unfertilized eggs and then they only
they wait to see which of them take and
you know
the thing is is that when you're
shooting that dna in there
it damages that dna and in the past the
animals that were born didn't live long
they had a lot of problems
if it's happening today i'm pretty sure
they're doing it with humans
but they're probably only doing it in
china
china has the laws that would allow it
they have the will and the rich people
have the money
and they would probably be doing it
very rich people might be might be
cloning their children
there might be a problem there there
might be got to have extras
well i would think they would probably
be genetically engineering them
which honestly if they had the
technology to do that which i'm sure is
not really that far off
i know there's like a lot of ethical
dilemmas and stuff i'm not saying that
but if you have the technology to
genetically engineer a kid that you were
going to have i don't want this kid
you know i want this kid to have all the
advantages because i don't want to have
all these diseases and all this hardship
and stuff like that
in a way i can see the appeal of that i
mean you don't want that's your kid you
don't want them to suffer
you want them to be successful you're
looking at it from a very western
high-minded perspective
well yeah and if you know the chinese
that's not what that's not what they're
concerned about
they're only concerned about looks um
looks how strong they are and what they
look like
if you there's a channel uh called
serpent za
go go um go watch that channel
it's about it's a south african guy who
uh lived he
left south africa and lived in china for
i think
13 years and
married a chinese woman who's a doctor
she's a
real good-looking woman that he married
and has a real good-looking
little daughter with her and they left
china
once he left china he's still on that
channel he was he's now in the united
states
i think he got asylum here he's kind of
more able to
talk about the way china really was when
living there and
there's a secret police and everything
you can even see um what do you call it
the chinese are odd the chinese do not
like how they look
they really actually like how western
people look well i think that's kind of
endemic across
yeah they don't like how they and what
they whenever they
they're online they face tune themselves
to look a lot more
western to me it looks like an e.t they
think it's western
they kind of want to look like um half
asian and half caucasian is what how
they want to look
they don't want to i guess
breed with caucasian people though they
they the these chinese people want to
have children with each other
and then have an amerasian looking child
that can only be done through genetic
engineering and cloning if you didn't
want to have
outside donors well they have all the
laws
and they have the technology in china
wouldn't surprise me if they're doing it
because i know that they're trying to
genetically engineer soldiers
they're also putting soldiers on super
soldier serum you know steroids
they're doing all kinds of stuff they
don't have the same ethical problems
well in a way like i said i can see that
there's ethical dilemmas because
there's kind of a thing but in a way i'm
kind of like if
all you're doing is i want my kid to be
good looking
like you can say that's shallow which it
is but
in another way good looking people get
treated better
so there might be a bigger and honestly
if you're not genetically engineering
um the kid that you pop out is just a
crap shoot yeah you don't know how that
kid's gonna turn out they might be like
fugly or something like that and like
they might get treated like crap because
of that which is sad but true
so it's kind of like i don't know i
don't really know how i feel about it
you know what i mean it's like it just
seems like
when you you they'll actually you know
you can you can go online and actually
see
like interviews with people there and
they're asking you know how
how they would want their children to
look and they just say the craziest [ __ ]
you know what i mean
they they're they're chinese and they
want kids with blue or green eyes they
want kids to be six foot something
they want kids that have like a
caucasian nose they call it a [ __ ]
big nose or a tall nose they want that
feature
they want certain [ __ ] hair they want
they like the black hair though
that's strange but uh they like uh
they like [ __ ] muscular builds but
the thing is though it's funny the
japanese guys will say the same thing
that's oh man
those those uh white guys those black
guys you know they look cool because
they're they're they're so big
i you know i was in korea there's they
say it's their skeletons
which is total [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah i
mean i was in
when i was in the army we had katusas
which are korean army argumentation the
united states army they were
they're koreans in the united states
army with us
as interpreters but they're south
koreans their skeletons were no
different really than
than american guys it's just that those
[ __ ] didn't work out
and they had they were eating a very low
protein diet so there's slender
well the thing about it too is that some
people like skeletons or no like some
people are just more slender than other
people
some people don't bulk up as much as
other people
it's just kind of like you know what i
mean well next to us there's a [ __ ]
korean special
uh special forces airborne unit they're
called the golden bats
which is one of their elite special
forces you can look it up that's a
pretty red the golden bats
it's like cheesy but also cheesy as [ __ ]
they look like [ __ ] spider from
[ __ ] johnny robot you know what i
mean remember johnny cycle the bad guys
oh my god i like that
wrap around glasses and [ __ ] yeah little
braces that's the perfect combination of
cheesy and awesome
yeah but they were they're big they were
big but they were all on steroids
looking back on it i thought they i
thought it was just genetic
but no now now that i'm [ __ ] educated
on the [ __ ] chemistry
they were all on steroids and you can
see videos of those guys too korean
special forces they're [ __ ] big
but that's because they worked out and
they ate right and they [ __ ] took the
proper supplements okay
you can get big quickly
but i'm saying you know what i'm saying
is that japanese guys
korean guys chinese guys they come up
with this we got small skeletons
[ __ ] you don't have a small skeleton
you just don't have any meat on your
frame
get in there and [ __ ] work out you
get big quick they can get big
they got some big jobs they got they got
chinese guys they're trying to [ __ ]
train for olympia yeah of course they're
taking roids but yeah if you're not
taking roads you can't go to olympia
that's a roid competition
that's you know every time you move your
head you're a little curled
yeah yeah yeah it's cause i'm pretty
[Laughter]
was that one getting prettier the more i
drink the prettier i get he's got beer
goggles on himself
got beer goggles on his [ __ ]
stuff
never mind anyone else hold on one
second he talked me out of this wig
i talked to you out of it i like i like
sexual enough i like that wig actually
he's not sexual enough i like it i'm
going i think you need the whole
outfit is what i think because i feel
like with that wig you need the whole
thing to go with it and then it would be
like really really awesome
that [ __ ] barbarian are you really
i'm gonna go [ __ ] conan with this
[ __ ] right
okay he's going conan all right
[Laughter]
i feel pretty needs to be tom's theme
song yeah yeah
yeah oh all right so
what was i talking about i don't know
what you're talking about ray aliens
i don't know what you're talking about i
don't know i forgot a lot i don't know
i don't listen to you ever yeah i don't
remember i lost track your shit's all
crooked
what are you even doing okay there we go
i mean you should know if like if if
it's this going like this over your face
then
it's it's like this shit's insane jenny
it's not it's insane okay no put it back
on it looks fine you had it i'm trying
to see where the front and the back is
okay these are the sides
yeah that side well yeah it's got like a
like i said it's got a little clip in
the back
yeah that's always in the back and you
just like do it underneath your i need
to
look at the nape of your neck stop
showcasing me stop
go back to the [ __ ] go back to the go
back to the to the fabric
i'm just getting a cone he's the one
making a big [ __ ] there's
there's a brush back there there's a
brush back there
i need the brush man get the brush i
need a brush he makes this big huge deal
he's back there like putting his arms
out like i'm gonna get the wig i'm gonna
do this and that and then like he yells
at me
like for i can't win it's all part of
the show i can't win it's all part of
whatever i do is not right how part of
the show i do it's not right all part of
the show
uh so yeah so we're talking about human
cloning because like i said
um because i said that raelians are very
very pro science like i said they're
very nano technology
uh fusion nuclear power like anything
that you know gmos anything that you
know technology can do to make
everybody's lives better
yeah uh they're all for that which like
i said you know that's uh pretty cool
because like i said usually they're not
retro usually yeah usually
religion and science are at odds which i
think is dumb
but um you know so yeah so they're into
like genetic engineering and all that
uh terraforming other planets whatnot
now
they made the news i don't think anybody
had heard of them really like at least
in the mainstream until i think it was
the early 2000s was it 2002 i want to
say
that's when their little company clonade
came out and claimed
that they had cloned the first human
baby
that it was like this little girl that
was born and her name was eve
and she was born in israel but
conveniently
they wouldn't show anybody uh her
and they wouldn't like give you know any
research on it or anything or said
say how they done it like they were like
oh well she's just a baby and we're
protecting her privacy and blah blah so
obviously like nobody believed it
i don't know if they actually did it or
not i don't even know
how would you even prove that honestly i
guess the only way you'd prove it is if
you had the baby well she wouldn't be a
baby anymore
but if you had the baby and then the
person that they cloned her from and
then they'd have the exact same dna
but they were like different ages that
would be the only way you could prove it
because honestly if they were both the
same age then they would just be twins
because twins are
nature's clones but uh yeah
so they're also into they want to do
some [ __ ] like
did you guys see the movie parts the
clonus horror it was not it was on mst
it was made in the 70s at some point um
the the company in there was making
clones
for like rich people would make clones
of themselves
so that if they got [ __ ] up like if
they lost a hand for example
like michael caine did in that movie um
then they could just cut the hand off of
the clone
and then they could just sew it on you
and it wouldn't be
rejected you know just handy dandy uh
but rather than just it's funny because
in the 70s they didn't really have a
concept of
we could just grow a hand from your dna
like in a petri dish or something which
they could probably do now
um they had to like grow a whole person
but then they didn't want that
person who was a clone knowing what was
going on so they had to keep them in
this facility and had to give them all
lobotomies so they'd be stupid and they
wouldn't figure it out
and then they just had to like entertain
them all the time so they wouldn't like
question
their life their lives you know what i
mean yep
it's um it's actually like a pretty
entertaining movie for one that was on
msd it's a bad movie
i think that movie there was a movie
that came out
in the 2000s [ __ ] man what was it called
was leonardo dicaprio in it i want to
say and the plot of it was almost
exactly the same
as parts the clones were and the dude
that made that movie like sued them i
don't remember if he won or not
but like the story was almost exactly
the same but yeah same that one in the
70s
and then one of the clones who was not
as rock stupid as the other ones like
actually figured out what was going on
and like escaped from the cloning
facility and like
met the person that he had been cloned
from and whatnot it was a whole it was a
whole thing
but uh but yeah so that so that's kind
of the first time i think that people
heard of
the raelians at least like in the
mainstream when they
came out and said hey we cloned a person
and we have this baby and she's named
eve
but like i said they wouldn't show any
proof so no one really believed them
everyone just thought they were full of
[ __ ]
although like i said it's not it's not
that crazy to think of i mean they had
cloned dolly
like the sheep at that point um
and you know so and it's not impossible
i just
they haven't the problem with cloning
humans is that you got to be real
cold-hearted
yeah because you gotta make about three
or four hundred clones
all right a lot of them will never be
born
and then some of them will be born you
might have about ten of them that'll be
bored
but out of that ten most of them will be
[ __ ] up they'll be dead soon
they'll have imperfections weird cancers
and problems
so you have to kill those basically it's
just like dog breeding
then you might end up with two you might
want to let those live for about 10
years until they're about 10 years old
and you go
and this one right here is [ __ ] up
it's going to have [ __ ] weird adrenal
program
problems part of the dna is [ __ ] up
kill that one this one here might live
to about 40 here take this one
there's that's what you wanted and then
you sell that one to the person
you got to be real [ __ ] cool this is
the good one this is the good one
because you have to make a bunch of them
it's a [ __ ] and then pick the best
one
because there's a too much of an error
rate well that's the thing about he
like you know you know they can clone
sheep and stuff like that which
you know they've been doing they were
all born [ __ ] up well and they've been
yeah they've been doing animal breeding
for thousands of years but it's just
kind of like there's
always that roulette that you're doing
because genetics is not an exact
science there's always anomalies there's
always mutations you never you can't
predict
yeah what exactly like you could put the
perfect
whatever like in there and still like
fortune's gonna throw some
wild card in the [ __ ] probably the
safest way to do it is [ __ ] take a
woman
and get about 10 or 10 of her eggs
and then man the the the husband that
you want
or whatever the donor that you want you
have him
[ __ ] bust a load and then you go
underneath the microscope
and get like 10 of the healthiest
[ __ ] sperm that you can see
look at that one's women right and you
impregnate all those [ __ ] little eggs
and you let them grow in an artificial
womb and you watch them
and then you let let them be born and
try to figure out which one is the best
one
all right and it might be that you might
want to let them
[ __ ] live for about five to ten years
and then look at him and go
this is the good one okay and then get
rid of the rest of them i think that one
might be a serial killer
yeah let's get rid of that well that
would be the best way
the best way to get a healthy
product it would be close to a clone but
now it wouldn't be a clone it would be
close to a genetic engineering it would
be
highly selective breeding that's what
that would be
yeah you the woman if the woman's
even sometimes a woman doesn't even if
she wants to have a
perfect child she doesn't even want her
genome involved
she could select an egg donor from a
woman that she says i want the woman to
look more like this
yeah cause it's like jesus i wouldn't
saddle some kid with like
right yeah you might want to look like
this i want the father to look more like
this
i don't want the kid to have my fat ass
then you might be able to kind of like
have a computer algorithm that would
generate what the probabilities
of 10 children would look like if they
were all male or female because you're
controlling the sex
yeah see when you let them be born and
once they get to a certain
age you judge one you go this is the
closest to what we wanted
we'll take this one the rest of them
kill these yeah
or adopt them out like doctor now you're
making like like when your cat has like
a little
bit not everybody could be doing that
because now you're making extra people
yeah all right you're talking about
genetic engineering or selective
breeding you're trying to
create a person you're not trying to
create a whole bunch of people just one
and that's what they that's how they
would do it i'm saying it's in it's in
very very inhumane
yeah and this is how dogs are bred
whole litters are born and they'll kill
the whole litter except one
a lot of people don't know that but in
real hardcore
dog breeding they kill most of the
puppies yeah they kill puppies
yeah they kill the little puppies though
these are these are not these don't have
what we're looking for this one is
closer
okay now breed that one with this one
and eventually we'll get there
and that was how they did all that [ __ ]
[ __ ] back in the honky motherland
back in the 1700s to breed these cattle
bigger
they're like eat let's eat these we'll
breed this one
eat these we'll breed this one they were
doing the same thing with the dogs
they were they were accelerating the
evolution yeah you got to be
cold-blooded
though yeah and that can only happen on
a farm
cause it cold-blooded on a farm it's all
food
you know what i mean yeah let the cows
grow we'll let them in about six months
we'll eat them
so they weren't wasting the meat burgers
on the hook we're gonna have yeah we're
gonna have
veal today because this had a cow is not
worth breeding
it doesn't have what we're looking for
you know that kind of [ __ ]
yeah scott said the movie i was thinking
about was the island that's it from
2005. yeah that was the one that was
almost exactly the same
of parts the clones are uh and then camp
guys said like in raising arizona i
think i got the best damn one
nathan jr i think yeah yeah i got the
best one yeah yeah
all that all of that baby all that
eugenics all that eugenics and human
engineering and [ __ ] to me
it's all cold-blooded scott says till 10
years old than trial by combat
yeah well the the the spartans were like
that
yeah yeah the kid had to go through an
initial inspection he was no good that
threw his ass away
you know and then they had to raise that
he had to be raised outside
to a certain period and they had to come
back he had to live as a bum
basically victor said sell them to
amazon so they can be put to work
[Laughter]
oh my god phil says i saw a show where
the mother
artificially inseminated her own
daughter how gross
wow wait so her like the daughter
was what infertile and so the mother
like contributed her eggs to the
daughter
which i guess i don't understand yeah
that would be pretty weird
it's weird yeah i mean but i guess
because the blood types and close to you
closer
yeah i can see like if one was infertile
and they're like yeah we need a close
relative
but still that'd be a little weird yeah
i'm giving birth to my own grandkids
yeah genetics it's [ __ ] up
but yeah so uh what else so the so the
raelians
uh you know other than being like very
pro-science like i said very
pro-technology very cloning they're into
cloning
uh they're also very anti-war very
anti-violence
um they're really really into that and
uh
also real into nudity like nudists
uh and uh real into free love like i
said we did we get to that eventually
so they think that pretty much their
only belief system
or at least as far as uh to hear them
tell it
is that that's kind of like the only
rule
is just love everybody so it's just that
that kind of thing now i don't know if
this is true or not but i did see this
referred to in like one documentary that
i saw about them
but apparently when they have
get-togethers and i've heard this about
some other groups as well
when they have get-togethers they have
all these different colored like
armbands
and that's just that's saying like who
you're open to have sex with like what
genders
you know what i mean yeah so it's just
kind of like well you barcode it out
yeah so you bar code so everybody knows
it's like hey
i'm open to this that and the other
thing and then so you know so everybody
is on the same page
evidently that's what nail polish color
was all about did you know that
is it really well am i in trouble
because my nail polish is green what
does that mean
i i always heard that in the 1800s i
just did it green so it would match my
neck i always heard that in 1800s
england nail polish color was really
just
uh a way of finding out what she was
selling
hmm that's interesting it was
color-coded
it's just kind of like back in the old
days like but the skin hit well back in
the old days back in the 80s the 70s and
80s with skinheads and they all had like
the different colored uh yeah
laces in their boots right like that
meant whatever yeah i don't remember
what all the colors i don't know but
that's true that's just whatever
that's what i heard i wasn't there
well i don't know if the color coded
bracelets is true or not right
but i have heard it and like some of the
some of the aliens did say it
like on the on the documentary that like
when they go to conferences or they go
to like
group get-togethers or whatever they
have like it's kind of like but like i
said
it's kind of like in a way
they're pretty chill because um
they're all about they don't like really
care like
if you're straight or gay or married or
not married or you want to be a total
hoe or it's like orgy time
they're just kind of like as long as
everyone's having a good time and
everyone's consenting then they don't
really have a problem with it
which is interesting because that's like
cool with me
but that has gotten them into trouble in
some countries like some countries don't
want them to come in because there's
like oh
they're um because they have a thing too
where i think they got in trouble
i can't remember what country it was in
but they got in trouble for
passing out condoms at a catholic high
school
which like i said i don't honestly have
a problem with that it's a high school
um you know but uh the catholics were
not happy
obviously um because i mean you're
passing out economy you're not making
the person use it you're not like hey
you know i'm going to make you have sex
with somebody they're like here if you
need this
catholicism no sex until marriage
no no no sex until marriage
hey poor yeah it's yeah it's that whole
thing so
so in a way i can kind of
i don't know they're just like real
chill with all kind of like like i said
as long as they don't seem to be like
doing like underage [ __ ] or anything
like that
it's you know maybe they are but i
haven't heard anything about it
um where's their headquarters i don't
know if they really have one
to be honest with you no okay well it
was formed in france
and that's where i don't want to say
that's where most of their followers
were
are but um it'd be awesome if it was in
roswell
they should maybe they should move it
there we're at the little alien
little alien a little right outside
roswell they had that damn [ __ ]
two-bit [ __ ] bar and [ __ ] hotel
called the little alien
yeah yeah it's [ __ ] yeah is that
still there anybody that's probably been
to roswell lately anybody but in new
mexico
i've been in new mexico i didn't go to
roswell though i want to say anything
but uh yeah so um so apparently so like
i said they go to a bunch they have
retreats they
all walk around naked um and some of the
people it's not like one of those
because you know how there's a thing
where you know when you get like a
a get-together of nudists and it's all
like a bunch of people you wouldn't want
us and no one would want to see you
like put your clothes back on oh yeah
it's just kind of like yeah okay my eyes
but um you know what i mean but it does
seem like a lot of these people are kind
of young and hot
so i think that's kind of why they got a
lot of which in a way
i can understand because it's a religion
in the sense that we believe that the
bible is true but only as far
as everybody is it's aliens here
um but other than that it seems like
amazingly chill
uh they don't they don't seem real
uptight about sounds like a [ __ ]
scene to me
yeah they don't seem super uptight about
you can't do this you can't do that you
can't they don't really seem to have
like a list of like commandments as such
okay um they don't really seem to
have a thing where let's go out and
convert people
they don't really seem to have anything
like that um
it just kind of sounds more like a click
yeah it doesn't
so in a way it's almost kind of like
there was i was reading this
um kind of really in-depth article about
it
it was like not even an article it was
like a really long paper
and they were kind of like debating
they're like well
we don't know if we can call this a cult
necessarily
because usually you know the definition
of a cult would be
charismatic leader which this does have
but
also there have to be like a bunch of
other parameters it usually has to be
you know people that are in cults they
usually cut you off from your outside
uh sources like you know you can't work
or you can't talk to your family or blah
blah or whatever
so it tries to tries to isolate you the
leader is usually trying to take
advantage
of other people in the group either
sexually or taking all their money or
both
um it's usually or you know and you
can't leave there's all kind of like
rules or like kind of [ __ ] about
leaving and you know it's very you know
they have an attitude
very us against them like the world is
evil and we can't go out in it
so it's kind of like so but it doesn't
seem like this really has that
but then in another way they were
talking about
well is this a religion then
and in some ways in some ways it is they
call themselves a religion
but i don't know if it is because a lot
of definitions of religion
have to do with you know essentially you
have like a supernatural being
who is watching over you and like gives
you a list of things
to do or not do or whatever which
this has to an extent in in that
you know the aliens are technologically
superior to us
but from everything that ryle has
written like in his books
he doesn't seem to be saying that we
should worship the aliens they are just
other beings
that happen to be more technologically
advanced who are willing to be cool
and help us out so let's do something to
help them out like build their embassy
and try to get our [ __ ] together on
earth so they can come here and hang
with us
um other than that it doesn't really
seem like he's trying to
you know he he's not really saying the
aliens say that you can't touch yourself
or see you know he's not doing anything
like that
you know what i mean it's it's just kind
of like you know jesus watches you while
you
jerk off kind of thing it's nothing like
that jesus
right so it's so it's so it seems like a
lot less
but then on the other hand and i was
like reading something i think it was on
um skeptic skeptoid or skeptics
dictionary or something like that
and they were kind of saying the same
thing they were kind of like well
as religions go it seems pretty chill
and like pretty cool and everything
but if you're gonna just let people
you know have sex with who they want and
you know drink and be
other religions if they want to be and
believe what they want as long as
everybody's cool
then it's like then why even bother
having the alien [ __ ] on top of it
like just do what you want and don't
worry about the aliens
yeah i don't know it it just seems like
another layer that doesn't need to be
there but i don't
maybe it's just the people that well
we like to party but we also like aliens
so that's the religion for you
sounds like to me um it just really does
kind of seem like that
they also have something called um
oh i was gonna say too that apparently
because because there is um there's an
offshoot i don't know if they're still
around
uh but there is kind of an organization
that's called riles girls
and these are all uh porn stars
all women and these are they're all
raelians
but they are they're kind of trying to
spread the message like sex positivity
but also you can be spiritual in the
sense of belonging to a religion even if
it's
one as loosely defined as this one and
still
get your freak on they're saying that
i'm prettier without being guilty you're
you what
they're saying that i'm prettier than
cher you're prettier than chair yeah
literally [ __ ] they're [ __ ]
saying if i could
[Laughter]
i'm trying to fix the [ __ ] trying to get
this [ __ ] silky straight
smooth [ __ ] heavy metal [ __ ] i
can't believe you've been over this
whole time i was talking he's over there
brushing his hair
trying to get some [ __ ] sexy ass
heavy metal hair
now do you see that those of us that had
really long hair like in real life not
just somebody
[ __ ] join [ __ ] ozzie's band are
you really yeah see it's a pain in the
ass
it's a pain in the ass right man you
look like like i said you look like a
human version of like the animated dudes
in death clock
yeah never seen it
that's what you look like look at how
fine tom is y'all you just don't
understand all that sexiness
[ __ ] gorgeous man [ __ ] gorgeous
oh my god so uh so yeah so what i was
gonna say that
like i said they have like a large
following in uh
japan particularly and also in south
korea
but apparently yeah they'd be into that
[ __ ] there yeah but apparently because
of that i guess um you got your
uh sexual tourists you know how people
do
uh i'm you know i'm gonna go to a
country where maybe some shit's
legal that's not legal in my country you
know what i mean uh so they'll do that
but i guess like some tourists have
twigged on to the fact
that um some raelians
will uh go to they'll pretend to be
aurelian and go to one of their like
meetings because they know that they'll
get laid
and they won't have to pay anybody and
it won't be like
you know having sex with some back alley
sex worker and getting a disease or
something that's i'm just saying that
that's kind of like what the perception
is
so it's just kind of like hey i'm an
alien too woo the aliens are coming
let's like let's all have a big free
love like [ __ ] pile now
and that's how it goes but like i said
as long as
everybody's willing to do it um
i don't know i really don't see a
problem with it that's
i have to say like i said no one's being
it seems like no one's being coerced to
do anything
which to me that's kind of that's kind
of the whole thing
what time is it it is 8 10 p.m okay
yeah we're halfway apart well yeah i
mean there's a bunch of [ __ ] in here
that i kind of already have anything
that i already kind of covered oh i do
actually have a commercial yeah i
thought that's what i thought
yeah i should probably go to the
bathroom watch you go ahead and take a
break let's go ahead and take a break
run a commercial are you going to mess
it up
i'm gonna mess it up i don't mess
anything up everything i do is [ __ ]
perfection
is it [ __ ] perfection we're not gonna
worry about it where's the commercial
it's right there strange reality is that
20 21. okay
and then go back and then go it's about
a minute and then you go back to maine
fullscreen
in 2019 the first strange realities
conference took place in nashville
tennessee
the pandemic in turmoil the following
year could not stop 2020's conference
from thriving in cyberspace
as a live streaming event now for 2021
the third annual strange realities
conference will combine these worlds
into a paranormal hybrid event live in
person in nashville
and streaming online join us in
exploring just how truly strange our
reality can be
with an interdimensional line-up of
speakers presenting unique and
intellectual perspectives on magic
mysteries and the paranormal featuring
greenfield dr j michael bennett aka dr
future
tim bernal soraya ascath dr steven
finley
aaron gulias amy pachula brent raines
chris ernst heather mosher michael
hughes
jose herrera joshua cutchen kiki
dombrowski
nathan isaac pd newman steven snyder
aka recluse david metcalf timothy renner
steve stockton and ren collier tickets
available strange
realitiesconference.com
it's gonna be amazing
[Music]
and we are back and i'm in the captain's
chair
let's see what everybody else is doing
i'm gonna come over here jenny will be
back in a second
we're just taking a break taking a break
getting all this [ __ ] beautiful hair
out of my damn face
here she is where'd you think i was no
no who what did she do over here
she [ __ ] threw all your [ __ ] on the
floor and laid down with it yeah
yeah oh she made a huge mess
for such a small cat she sure does she
sure does make a big [ __ ] mess
yeah i forgot to say too i'm
completely going where no wig has gone
before uh
yeah so are we gonna be in nashville for
that conference probably not
god i've been in nashville since i was a
little kid
flip the hair tom i am flipping it let's
get in my face yeah
stop showcasing stop showcasing yeah i'm
just i think it's funny because
you know when i wear long ass wigs all
the time because he's like oh you look
good with long hair so i wear that and
like all night i'm like oh jesus
and it's like falling in my drink and
getting caught in my jewelry and
[ __ ] like that i'm like yeah see it's
not fun is it and he can only wear it
for like an hour or two and he's like
man [ __ ] this it's too hot
i know sometimes i have to wear that for
hours and hours
tila says tom spock is looking over your
shoulder like a crazy brush in that wig
it's not amused he's over in the mirror
universe he is yeah
he's going to get ready to use the
agonizer on me he's judging he's always
judging
yeah always ensign ross you're agonizer
give me your agonizer
i love that episode i do too yeah well
like i said
i like the sequel to that episode too
which is on [ __ ] star trek continues
if you guys haven't seen star trek
continues man it's free on
on youtube it's [ __ ] in hd that
that's real star trek for me
i like i love star trek continues it's
the third it's the final season of that
because when that [ __ ] went off the air
they just left it just
and then star trek the motion picture
started you know what what the [ __ ]
happened to spock why was this
why was spock back on vulcan all that
[ __ ] is answered in that final season
and a lot of the same people that
[ __ ] worked on the old epis on the
old
series worked on star trek continues man
that's a real star trek
yeah what i was going to say was that
uh mst also did a mirror episode they
did like a parody of that
yeah and that's why so every time you
say give me your agonizer please it
cracks me up because yeah
because mike did that as well that was
one of the most dramatic [ __ ]
um scenes like mike was on
mike was on the um was in deep 13 and he
had a goatee
and yeah he looked all evil well check
this out they're gonna
i was so funny check this out they're
going to agonize you
okay yeah they're going to agonize you
with the technology
but you have to carry your own agonizer
that's some [ __ ] yeah you know like yeah
that's it that'd be like in the old days
when you had to carry your own switch
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
so uh so also the you know since we're
talking about the whole uh free love
you know sex or do you think they also
have something called
sensual meditation and uh ryle himself
has written a book called sensual
meditation
which you can read online uh and i read
some little
uh pieces of it and it's delightful
so probably you should go read it
amanda's a
star trek continued fantasy yeah yeah
with vic mignona
mcdonough love that gorgeous man i like
vic vic is [ __ ] awful uh
he's cool he's real cool he's he and
and look there's only two
[ __ ] there's only two [ __ ] captain
kirks
well there's only there's one captain
kirk that's william shatner all right
that was his role but vic vic mignon
magnonia
magnonia that's how you say right
nignonia i can't [ __ ] say a
motherfucker's name
vic is the best kirk that isn't
that isn't william shatner it's real
close and he's not doing a shot in her
impersonation
it's just he's just doing he's just
doing captain kirk and it just
after a couple episodes you're like yeah
that's kirk
you know yeah i kind of forgot after a
while
he has a slightly different spin on it
but not really different
no he doesn't it's not a different spin
it's just he's not doing a william
shatner impersonation
you'll see phil says you know william
shatner actually put an album out yes he
did
he spoke with the songs yeah it was well
there was one that was like kind of
famous
he was kind of doing covers of sort of
well-known songs he did but he's in this
guy with diamonds yeah he did that was
the one that i remember the moosie
in the sky with diamonds
she was terrible yeah well he could yeah
but it's funny for like it's ironic
value
yeah um you know
[Laughter]
tila said is it real or a joke because i
would want to hear that yeah no it's
real
it's real uh well leonard and moy put it
in an album
yeah which uh the song i remember the
most about that was the one about the
hobbit yeah
yeah which uh and they put these out in
the 60s it's like it's cringy but also
it's
kind of awesome i don't know they put
these out in the 60s
i think right i think it was right after
the the show went off the air
wasn't it right after they went off the
air or maybe not not too long after
yeah the ship was terrible it was
but i i kind of appreciate it for its
ironic entertainment value
was i because i fight okay was william
shatner
ever in on the joke of william shatner
yeah i kind of feel like he was but then
sometimes
have you guys seen what the [ __ ] was
that movie uh
a christmas horror story that uh
anthology
like that christmas horror movie and the
wraparound was william
shatner who was playing a radio dj
and he was got drunker and drunker as
the course of the movie went on and it
was just like he was so [ __ ] good in
that so i
so seeing him in that like really kind
of cemented
yeah my feeling that he's kind of
inaudible
why is it everybody on the whole cast of
that show despised william shatner
i don't know if they despised him it's
just that they [ __ ] were sick of his
[ __ ]
all right well he seemed very much like
he thought he was the captain yeah
he thought they worked for him right
which he thought he was that was that
real
that [ __ ]
they'd be in between scenes and he'd be
barking orders at people like he was the
captain
and they were like [ __ ] i don't work
for you i work for these i work for the
studio you know
no more government gave me some coffee
yeah yeah yeah and he'd be like yeah he
thought he was captain kerr
go get it yourself your arms aren't
broken that's my dad but no he was in on
the joke [ __ ]
the shot knew that he was [ __ ] out of
control
yeah he does have some he does have some
self-awareness yeah he knew and that dj
maniac said glenn danzig
isn't even in on the joke about him no
no he's no he's not
but like i said that's what neither is
steven seagal that's another thing that
we've talked about
you can be as obnoxious as you want
as long as you're self-aware enough to
know that you're obnoxious
and like if people call you out on it
and like make a joke about it you
roll with the joke the second you become
an insufferable douchebag is when you're
like that
but you don't realize that you're like
that and like you're like that seriously
and when people make fun of you you get
like all butt hurt about it
that's the difference yeah the chat
knows that he's the chat though
he just tries to play it off like he
doesn't know but he knows exactly what
it is
yeah he just tries to play it off
mango said he even admits now that his
ego was a tad big back then
yeah well yeah that's what everybody
that's what everybody he thought he was
the captain
c c can you imagine can you imagine
like just being one of a bunch of actors
like working on some [ __ ]
yeah he you got this other then you got
this other actor who's just the same as
[ __ ] as you
like hey i was a waiter a week ago and
he's just like ordering you around
like he's like your [ __ ] boss or
something he was in the cabin curt role
[ __ ] all the whole time yeah i'd be
like how about you grab a ladder and
jump
up my butt but yeah it'd be that whole
kind of situation
so i can see how that might uh rub
people the wrong way sure yeah
[Laughter]
but yeah so but the i the bitchiness
between them i kind of feel like that
made the show better
well you know there was a triad going on
you know it was kirk
spock and bones those [ __ ] ran
that whole show eventually
by the time season two ran around came
around the show was focused on those
three characters and they were you have
one dude who's a [ __ ] brave leader
who's [ __ ] real impulsive
and emotional that's kirk and then you
got this [ __ ] cold calculating
[ __ ] logical guy who sometimes
gives in to his emotions that's spock
and then you got [ __ ]
bones mccoy who's this totally [ __ ]
flawed human
who's just how dare you you know he's
cussing them both out all the time you
know
[ __ ] who's totally emotional you're
just a robot
you know he's saying that [ __ ] the
[ __ ] your vulcan mom you must be out
of your vulcan mind
you know
graham [ __ ] i'm a doctor i'm not a
bricklayer just [ __ ] like that
grantham's hammer said galaxy quest was
a perfect parody of star trek
it absolutely was actually galaxy quest
is so so good
we actually got it somebody somebody
sent it to us uh on blu-ray so we need
to do like a matinee on that one of
these days because i really like that
movie
i always kind of feel like i'm i mean
spock is kind of my spirit animal
um you know i feel spock's pain but i
feel like i have a little bit
i'm a little bit of bones as well like i
kind of feel like spock and bones
together are kind of like that's kind of
that's that's my deal
you know what i'm saying that's kind of
what i'm like because i love how [ __ ]
uh cranky bones is because i'm cranky
like that too
yeah seagal actually threw a guy at a
pool for asking him
about his being a cop you know when i
was scrolling through
toby the other day i saw that the steven
seagal lawmen show
is on there on toby and i was like do i
dare
stephen steven seagal
law man i don't know if i could sit
through a whole episode of that
yeah he walks around [ __ ] um
pretending that he's black
yeah i'm not sure yeah yeah
she's got that michigan accent i kind of
wanted to watch it and i was kind of
like
do i really hate myself that much is
this how low i've sunk
he's down in louisiana he tries to turn
that michigan accent into ebonics every
time he's dealing with a [ __ ] black
guy
you know man i'm trying to tell you
holmes
that you know wait hold on are we in l.a
or or are we in [ __ ]
oh my god i wish i'd been there and i'd
be like excuse me i speak jive
[Laughter]
he wouldn't have got that joke either
he's up in russia he's so lame
he just gave charges victor says spock
is my spirit animal by proxy because
jenny is my spirit animal
victory i'm really someone spirit animal
that's neat
but yeah i just kind of like see that's
why i love it see i love that sophie got
me that
spock back there because like every day
i'm in here working and i can look
behind and i'm like spock
please judge me but it's like that's
kind of what my face looks like all the
time too so i get it
um so look can we talk about like i said
the centralization is a little sensual
meditation
like i said it's not like a huge amount
about this i'm just kind of like blue
sky about the [ __ ]
but um hold on grantor said that he saw
stevenson god once at the shot show in
vegas to do his massive
yeah but he's [ __ ] fat though massive
as in
like i mean he is tall but he's just a
big fat guy because we know because we
know he's a big fat guy
that yeah well like i said he's getting
to the point now where they can't even
like fit his entire [ __ ] fat ass in
the frame so it's like they just show
him from the neck up
he's he's got a stunt double to go up
and down the stairs for him yeah
when he's got to stand up and walk out
of a room they got a stunt double for
that because
that movie we watched the other day
where it's like he had a stunt double
like the stunt double walked out on the
balcony and looked out the balcony and
they didn't even try to like pretend
that that wasn't him
no it wasn't him that easily wasn't him
every time i showed him even though it
was supposed to be him but it
so clearly was not spirit animal church
you got a 10 super chat from victor
thank you very much
yeah i mean every time they show every
show here at animal surcharge
in all the newer seagull movies that i
was [ __ ]
looked at i didn't watch them i looked
at it because they're unwatchable
[ __ ] um i like that now next time i
see a movie that i can't not res
well i looked at it it didn't really
like penetrate
they'll have him sitting down and
there's always something in front of him
so all you see is his head
and he's talking and it's a big old head
just yeah
and he's supposed to be in these [ __ ]
badass mercenary groups with all these
[ __ ]
mercenaries doing [ __ ] dangerous [ __ ]
tim worthinger [ __ ] like what kind of
like yeah
mercenary and they're in [ __ ] i'm
like dude you're like
20 years or 20 years out of date for
being a [ __ ]
frontline mercenary we're out there
[ __ ] gaking [ __ ] that's a
young man's game for the most part
well 20 years and 200 pounds yeah and
i'm like you know
and then like all the other dudes that
are serving with them you know nah
40s and 50s and that's a wrap okay
here's something to [ __ ]
arnold arnold played a mercenary and
predator one that was a whole team of
mercenaries going there to save some
sf guys they were ex-sf guys or um
at least he dutch was arnold i think was
42 at the time he [ __ ] looked great
for 42.
could a 42 year old look like that do
that [ __ ] right they could
a 52 year old that looked like that
could do that
but not not not [ __ ]
steven seagal no
no he needs to like knock off the hohos
if he really wants to
actually that first or maybe second
expendables could
could um could
uh or what's his name could [ __ ] um
what am i thinking of
that dude's name
dude from rambo especially yeah what's
that fucker's name just call him rambo i
don't know who he meant
[Laughter]
could sylvester stallone pulled off
that mission out of expendables one and
two yeah probably he was in real good
shape could he had done that in [ __ ]
that rambo
that [ __ ] badass rambo movie where he
shot all those dudes up
his face is [ __ ] up but no he was in
great shape he could have done that
but no not steven's ago
[ __ ] though i'm just saying that's just
right now you know
that dude's sitting around his house
going into the pool
pool full of asian experience you got an
asian girl in the pool he's [ __ ]
pouring the [ __ ] out you know
you know i like my asian experience baby
come here
come here baby she's like yeah no thanks
you know i love you
you know his pool's full of twinkies
yeah yeah you know i love you
[Laughter]
i always got a hat asian experience baby
yeah i couldn't believe like i saw that
and i couldn't believe it was real
yeah you know what i'm saying and i was
just kind of like
wow blowing my [ __ ] mind
do you know how much a [ __ ] can of
asian experience
unopened goes for now on ebay well yeah
it's like two people love the [ __ ]
it's irony value it's irony value
like i said the dude from cinemassacre
yeah not james not the main dude but
like one of the dudes that was
like on the you know on the video
reviews or whatever
he is uh a big ironic fan of steven
seagal
and like not in like he's bought like
every single steven seagal thing like in
existence
and he bought a can of it off ebay
that was still unopened and he drank it
on the show and it was like super funny
oh goody we have another troll
it's the same one it's probably the same
one oh my god get a life y'all
but it's just i don't know it's
the first time i saw that i don't know a
lot of steven seagal stuff i just can't
believe
i don't know i just it makes my skin
crawl because there's no there's no
sense of like i'm being ridiculous right
now
like if he had a sense of i'm being
ridiculous right now it would be
hilarious
but because he doesn't have that it just
comes across as like really cringy and
embarrassing and it's like i have like
secondhand embarrassment so i can't
watch it
you know what i mean it's it's really
like difficult for me to watch
um yeah so what were you talking about
oh sensual meditation
steven seagal would know all about that
[Laughter]
he's essentially meditating uh with his
asian experience uh
stuff yeah so they have these seminars
like i said
uh rael wrote a book about it this is
another thing that the aliens apparently
told me to do
because i guess so they do these
seminars they're like two weeks long
and they have them um all over the world
every year
and they kind of um i guess it's b
it's basically like a big [ __ ] fest
they're not doing sensual meditation
it's just like a big orgy i guess
these are one of the places where they
wear the [ __ ] bands or whatever
uh to let everybody know what's going on
so i guess the whole point of this
is um this is what the
this is what the website says it says
sensual meditation
is designed to rectify this the many
inconsistent values conditioned by our
present society by teaching people to
start questioning
all their values and consequent actions
so as to be able to decondition oneself
uninhibit oneself that's very important
uh and appreciate the present in a much
deeper way
enjoying every sensation with a maximum
of pleasure and love without the
paralysis
of society's guilt so it's meant to
exercise and develop the senses
somebody mentioned sting doing the
tantric sex earlier that's
kind of oh so you brought that up i've
talked about that before
sting needs to get over the [ __ ] self
it's so funny what fame would do to
certain people of the 80s
famous [ __ ] [ __ ] up just look
at sting
he went mainstream as a [ __ ]
running around his damn pajamas [ __ ]
singing to middle-aged women and [ __ ]
shame on that dude well that's where the
money is you have to understand i'm very
cool i'm very cool and i'm spiritual me
and you
you're gonna we're gonna burn candles
and sit down and drink tantric sex
i love you even though you're overweight
baby it's just all kinds of weird [ __ ]
you know
[Laughter]
that's what that was stings gig man
[ __ ] after all that [ __ ]
i'm a very like not the second somebody
comes at me from that angle of like
spiritual this and that and the other
i'm just like bye you know what i mean
it's just like
i don't know i can't hang with that yeah
um i can't hang with people that are
i'm not saying i i don't like because i
do like people that are like
honest and i like people that are like
earnest and like geeky about
things i don't mind that but this whole
thing about
i don't i don't know like that whole new
agey thing that's why as much as i read
about this cult uh you know a religion
or whatever
it's because i don't think it's
necessarily a cult but um
as much as i read about it i said well
they seem pretty cool like they have
like
you know they don't have any like
horrible beliefs or anything not really
they have like a couple that are kind of
like
like kind of questionable but you know
they they're kind of like a one world
government type of thing which you know
i don't know about that but
um you know but most of their [ __ ] is
fine
uh but even then i don't know i was
watching the documentary and i said
would i really want to hang out with
these people no
yeah no i just wouldn't it just it just
seemed like it would
get on my nerves because for for the
same way that i wouldn't want to hang
out with steven seagal because he
doesn't have a sense of humor about
himself
yeah [ __ ] actually i would just [ __ ]
a while yeah i would hang out with
seagal just so i could get some material
but
i couldn't hang out with [ __ ] sting i
feel like a sting seemed to be pretty
cool up until he was maybe in his mid
late 30s because i love the police man
yeah
but it seemed like the older he got just
a more up his own ass
he went he's one of the yeah pro tip
please don't vanish up your own
he just vanished up his own no matter
how rich and famous you may get
well it gets you're still just a lowly
[ __ ]
you sing and you play music yeah like
don't you
don't get some inflated sense of like
that you're some spiritual being or yeah
it was tim and bono
him and bono well bonna's worse just up
their own asses like poof
dude you turned inside out you just look
at a bunch of faces
veins and mucus membranes
you start completely yeah and i think
that that that came from hanging out
with too many goddamn rich people
or something well i kind of something i
don't know like i don't know i don't
know from experience obviously because
i've always been a broken [ __ ]
but
i you know i kind of feel like having so
much money
would just like insulate you from
everything i mean it would really
insulate you from i think those two guys
went into echelons above reality they
ended up that's what i'm saying
they just ended up hanging out in
people's [ __ ] private yachts and
private
you don't have to like do anything that
you don't want to do
yeah they going to they end up on mind
blowing they end up on mount olympus
basically
and they're talking down to you and all
this spiritual [ __ ]
they're going to save the world by the
power of the [ __ ] fingers and the
strings and their guitars
send me [ __ ] money i need a couple
more million and all
feed these people over here over in
africa i'll take 90 percent we won't
talk about that
but you know and the [ __ ] trickles down
to giving a [ __ ] little african kid a
little [ __ ] peppermint
you got it yeah yeah thank you you gave
me millions of dollars they got a
peppermint
you know i don't give a none of those
[ __ ] charities they're all rip-offs
i mean i don't know it's just saw a show
on what
what those charities how much they
actually charge how much of that
actually makes it to the ground on what
they're talking about it's like
one percent i mean it depends on the one
you really have to be careful about the
one julius because a lot of them
well yeah a lot of them are in in the
sense that you know a large percentage
goes to like administrative
administration like that our overheads i
got to pay my bills and things like that
which you know
i don't know it's just it
as i said i've never been a rich person
and i'm not saying that if i won the
[ __ ] lottery tomorrow
i wish um but if i did like
would i vanish up my own ass yeah you
know
i don't know i kind of feel like i
wouldn't but then everybody says that
you need to vanish up your own ass
i'm maybe i'm too i'm too cranky to like
vanish at my own ass
if it had happened to me when i was
young maybe but
these guys vanished up their own asses
while they were in their late 20s
yeah so they were never seen again
[Music]
no one knows where they are he knows
what that [ __ ] is just never
seen again vanished up his own head
turned inside out
if you see a two-legged thing that's
pink with a bunch of veins in it and
[ __ ]
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] but the uh i'm just
i'm one of those people i just feel like
and i'm not saying it i don't know i i
kind of feel like don't don't
be like so down on yourself that you
think like you suck forever because
like i've had problems with that but on
the other side of that coin
don't be a person that thinks you're
like more awesome than everyone else
because you're not
yeah you know what i'm saying it's like
a really hard balance and i also gotta
[ __ ] say though that
[ __ ] u2 was great it was a great band
and so was the police and staying solo
was [ __ ] great yeah and i'm not
[ __ ] on those two bands because
actually i really really love those two
bands
yeah they were good i mean they're not
world saving good but who is
nobody they were products of the media
of their time
yeah because you know what i mean
everything was channeled through just a
few channels and a few radio stations
and um the powers that could be could
pick a man
and turn them into a superstar and then
that would really go to your head
because
i guess if you were that man you thought
that that was all
like natural of course i'm the [ __ ] no
it's actually very unusual everyone's
saying something
yeah right yeah but if you were to open
it up today with like an internet and
youtube and [ __ ] your ass would [ __ ]
vanish
because of the competition well yeah now
in a way
um i don't there are some things i don't
like the way the media is nowadays but
it's like
in a way it's kind of better now it's i
think it's harder
everybody has a chance well one
everybody has a chance and
two i feel like you're not as insulated
as from the public as you used to be
because i feel like
even famous people if you have like a
twitter account or a facebook or
something like that
you are going to get [ __ ] tons of people
telling you that you suck
and you know what i mean so yeah in a
way that's kind of like balancing it
maybe kind of keeps you like
there's nothing they can't be on mount
olympus anymore that will [ __ ] cost
you your career
look what happened to [ __ ] gina gina
corrado from the mandalorian
[ __ ] there was an inter war went on
between her and people in disney they
tried they kicked her out
but she went right to youtube and
[ __ ] went right to her fans and ended
up [ __ ] being on people's [ __ ]
podcasts
and people loved her she's [ __ ] just
a nice [ __ ]
chick she's [ __ ] fun you know she got
her [ __ ] job back
because people aren't special anymore
everybody
is [ __ ] in the same game now it's not
like it was well when everybody
is special in their own way like
everybody's an individual
everybody has something they can offer
maybe most people and if you're
and if you're a [ __ ] star
that everybody's kind of a star on
youtube in a certain way
but if you're one of these hollywood
stars you better be able to have the
skills to go on youtube and go
on the damn podcast that talk about your
movies
and get down in the trenches with the
people and if you can't compete in that
realm
you're not going to be a star for very
long because your social media presence
is what dictates if you're star or not
it's not like it back in the old days
where you just be pretty on camera
because they want to know who you are
well like i said i kind of feel like
there's even people that aren't
super super famous but are like internet
famous or social media famous
yeah and they're morphing and they get
some of these and some of them are more
famous
at least with certain demographics of
the demographics that matter to that
[ __ ]
person to that [ __ ] star but what i'm
saying is
saying if you try to be an old-fashioned
star like from the 90s
or the 2000s or the 70s it's not going
to work in the day in the era of the
social media it won't work
you've got to get on social media people
have to know who you are
or they're or they're not really going
to care about you
i do kind of feel like people are maybe
more responsive
nowadays to authenticity or at least the
appearance of
authenticity you can't just be cause i
feel like back in the old days
people really liked all these like movie
stars and stuff like that because they
were like unattainable they were almost
like supernatural beings yeah and that's
gone
yeah you didn't like see them in their
regular life you didn't see them like
hanging out at the grocery store you
didn't see them like in their pajamas
making
[ __ ] videos on youtube on the screen
right that's what i'm saying so it was
very easy to like them for them to be
idealized
yeah very good way of putting it and
like a good example of what you're
talking about i mentioned it earlier
i guess about six months ago johnny depp
johnny depp he [ __ ]
did a lot of good movies i liked the guy
uh when he went through that thing with
a with i think his amber heard was the
name his
big divorce with the wife he tried to do
his first [ __ ] like
social media [ __ ] campaign where he
went out
hey people i just wanted to tell you in
any way the way he came across
on social media was so awkward and so
unnatural
that he came off as like i felt sorry
for him
well he's not used to it he's not used
to having to interact with just
didn't
which i kind of felt bad for him because
he felt
he he came across as a very
outdated you know what i'm talking about
yeah like i mean he tried at least
he needs to relax he needs to stop
playing johnny depp
the characters well people would
probably like him they like him
maybe unless he's a giant very
artificial
like he was on a talk show just knock
that off man [ __ ] just talk
you know which it takes i guess maybe it
takes time
because he has a theatrical background
so he's always on stage and
he's doing what they told him well
people and the thing about it man actors
in particular you don't see that so much
with musicians
but actors i mean their whole job is
pretending to be other people
so it's harder for them to just come
across as real because they're always
used to like putting on a different
thing
so i can see that i think that's why
gina kicked so much ass when she just
went right to [ __ ] social media to
[ __ ]
save her image because she's not an
actress she was a fighter
and she got in there and she was just a
normal person and [ __ ] went to go
meet youtubers that had [ __ ] hundred
thousand views
she'd show up [ __ ] to the restaurants
with them
and just talk you know what i mean and
that got her her [ __ ] [ __ ] back on
the
on the mandalorian and her show
rangers of the new republic evidence is
going to come out thank you victor and
it's because
he gave me some money because i said hoi
polloi
it's because the celebrity of the future
will be
a real person who is very adept and
people like them
and everybody knows who they are from
their social media profile
the old version of celebrities gone
can i say that one of my favorite
youtube videos that i've watched in the
past week
i think i mentioned her on wednesday
i like i'm subscribed to this channel uh
she's called jade the libra
and she's really into like halloween and
like spooky [ __ ] she does like scary
books and stuff
and she's like she's gorgeous gorgeous
gorgeous she's um she's from case she
lives in kansas i think with her husband
and she does videos where she decorates
her house for halloween and [ __ ] like
that
and the other day she had done a video i
think it's it's probably like a few
months old
where she did like she cleaned out um
her entire bathroom like all the makeup
and stuff because i think for a long
time she worked in like makeup so she
had like a bunch of [ __ ]
and she cleaned it out and she showed
herself like cleaning her shower
and just all this other stuff and it's
just kind of like it's so funny that
people would watch that nowadays
but it's like i really liked that
because she's like this beautiful like
model
looking girl and she's just not afraid
to like show herself with no makeup on
with crappy clothes on
cleaning her disgusting ass shower and i
was just kind of like that made me so
happy because i'm like hey my shower's
gross too and i like hardly ever clean
it
and it's like so it made me feel a lot
better about myself
because i was good she was because her
shower was dirtier than mine and i was
just like yes
but i think that's kind of people
respond to that because
you know you know yes they might look sh
you know she looks amazing and
everything like that but she's still
like a person
and you're just seeing her do regular
person [ __ ] like you do
yeah there's some people out there upset
she's not back on yes she is she's back
off
trust me
range of the rangers of the new
republic's coming back too she's going
to be in that
get mad if you want to but no it's back
on what are you doing polka what's up
tammy said so the new celebrities will
be jenny and tom yeah
yeah i've i've seriously one time
when we were at that horror convention
and
um i was on a panel about something and
i had somebody in the audience like come
up to me and say that they watched our
show
but that's like i think that's the only
time i've been out in public and like
somebody
man your wig like went way back yeah
like you got all kind of forehead
showing
thorn says dan says i love jade the
labor i do too like some days
i don't know man i'll just like watch
like a [ __ ] hour-long video
of her decorating her house for
halloween or like walking around
michael's
like looking for halloween decorations i
don't know she's like she's so
[ __ ] cute and she's so funny and it's
i don't know why like i said i watched a
whole like hour long video of her
cleaning her bathroom
but you know that's just what people
it's 20 21 and that's what people do
nowadays
we watch beautiful people clean their
disgusting showers
on youtube that's all right though like
i said
it's you know you just get to see
like people doing the same [ __ ] that you
do like everybody's
the same i i don't like i don't
necessarily like the uh
the kind of mystique that people used to
have like they didn't
like they almost like were super human
or like i don't know i don't think
that's a really healthy attitude to have
you know what i'm saying
yeah camp guy said i used to watch
joe rogan on fear factor just to see
what they had to eat
i started watching that it's like i
couldn't really
i'm not grossed out by a lot of stuff
but i am absolutely grossed out by
people eating
gross [ __ ] i think one time
i saw a fear factor where someone had to
eat was it a banana slug
although i was like what man leave that
slug alone don't do that
no they eat all kinds of stuff though is
the show and that kind of like made me
really sick israel i'm trying
well i'm trying to like think of um yeah
i talked about them giving out the
condoms they got in trouble for that
that was 1992.
and then i kind of talked about like the
difference between
cults and religions and whether
i did forget to mention that the
raelians
actually their calendar they started
counting
from the um the bombs dropping on
hiroshima and nagasaki so
much in line with a lot of like ufo
religions they kind of
it's kind of like a sci-fi type of thing
where they kind of
uh it's all tied up with uh
you know with post-world war ii
nuclear kind of stuff uh so i think i
forgot to mention that it's not like a
huge deal but that's like where their
calendar starts
uh from from there and um
i was gonna say that ryle said that he
got chosen
for being a prophet or whatever because
he was born a year after uh the atomic
bomb
that's why um yeah so and i had some
notes about
because they were talking about like
other ufo cults obviously like heaven's
gate which we already did a show about
uh there was one in the 50s called the
aetherius society
uh which is similar kind of thing but um
another thing too that i wanted to say
that
i think one of the i mentioned that the
raelians didn't really seem to have
any really terrible
um you know kind of [ __ ] against them
like no one's
telling everybody like you know like i
said it's not like scientology where
it's like oh they threw somebody in a
hole or
you know somebody disappeared or
somebody like committed suicide quote
unquote uh
except not so it's nothing like that
i think the worst thing that i found
about them was that
a lot of people like later on uh
accused rael of plagiarism
which is pretty mild as cults go um
basically like ripping off a lot of his
stuff
from like um different books
mostly by a dude named i think his name
is jean
cendy i think is his name and um so all
this stuff about like you know the world
should be run by geniuses
and all that kind of stuff that came
from that dude's book
um but so that's like the worst thing i
heard about him pretty much
was that other than now i did see i
don't think this was on the wikipedia
page
but i did remember somebody saying that
his first wife he's had three of them
not at the same time um that his first
wife i think he married her when she was
16
which creepy uh i don't know how old he
was i don't think he was that much older
but it's still kind of creepy uh but
that was pretty much the worst kind of
sexual [ __ ] that i heard about
um but other than that like all of his
people have said that most of his major
ideas like he just ripped him off from
other places
or just like large portions of his books
were
taken from other people's books
particularly like ufo type of writings
from the 50s and 60s
which not good but if that's like the
worst [ __ ] then people can come up with
uh against him not really all that
worried about it
also honestly um
in a way they've done a lot of good
because they had like this really big
program
that they started in africa and other
parts of the world
where they were um campaigning like
pretty vociferously against uh female
genital
mutilation and they were trying so they
were trying to like do a big
campaign against that and they were
trying to like you know help people that
it had done to them and you know giving
them
uh you know surgeries free of charge and
stuff like that so it did
seem like they were doing some kind of
good so
like i said a lot of their beliefs are
not all that nefarious
um as far as that type of thing goes
as i said in a way you could call them
creationists because as pro-science as
they are
they don't really believe in
evolution in the sense that a scientist
would believe in evolution
because they believe that aliens
genetically programmed us the way that
we are now so they don't believe
that that humans evolved
you know evolved from a common ancestor
with apes they don't believe that
they believe that humans were
genetically engineered and then put here
by
aliens so so they're
creationists in that way but like i said
they're not which
you know i'm kind of i have a thing
about creationists but they're not
creationists in the same way that like
christian that christians would be
creationists in the sense that they just
think well i don't know it is kind of
the same though isn't it because they're
just kind of
i mean creation to say oh god created
the created humans and they're saying
aliens created humans so it's really not
that much different
but at least they're not trying to get
it taught in schools at least as far as
i know
i think the [ __ ] creationist maybe
gave up on that
i've read a bunch of books um because i
feel like in the
it was like it was probably like the 90s
or early 2000s there was like this big
thing where
at least in the u.s in the midwest and
the south
um creationists were trying to
get intelligent design taught
in science classes uh because they were
saying it was scientific and everything
like that because i remember like
reading a bunch of [ __ ] about that at
that time and
those i don't know for some reason those
people just like kind of pissed me off
but i don't know it's when you're saying
it's aliens for some reason it doesn't
piss me off as much i guess because it
sounds kind of goofier
and they're not maybe because we're not
in any danger of
of anybody taking that seriously i don't
know
i guess that's why it is but it doesn't
offend me as much although the more i
think about it it's like not really any
different than
saying then kind of denying what that
like i said that's really ironic because
they are
very pro-science in a lot of ways
they're pro-technology
i don't know if they're necessarily
pro-scientific method but they seem like
pro-technology anything that would help
humans
lives improve anything that would make
humans like live longer that's one of
the big reasons that they're
super into genetic engineering and stuff
like that because they want humans to be
able to live
as long as possible um you know and they
think that the only way to do that is by
through cloning like growing body parts
all this kind of stuff
it's just getting too hot i can't take
it jenny i can't take
i can't god damn i can't take it i wear
those like all night at the club
dancing and everything and it's like you
don't see me whipping that [ __ ] off
with my [ __ ] cat man dudes dudes
can't put up with anything
it was getting to my [ __ ] face too
well yeah i know
why don't you wear a wig and a corset
and high heeled shoes and see how long
you last with that
yeah granthar's hammer says creationists
believe the world is six thousand years
old
older uh old earth creationists and
young earth creationists are different
young earth creationists absolutely do
believe the world is six thousand years
old like literally
old earth creationists are willing to
um say that the six days or whatever in
the bible
actually referred to like millions of
years
so they're kind of willing to give like
the timeline
you know they're they're willing to go
that far but
they still think that god did it and
that dinosaurs aren't real
and stuff but because i was talking
about how
the raelians are kind of creationists
just
in a slightly different way than the
christians because they actually don't
believe that humans evolved from
you know a common ancestor with apes
they actually think that aliens
genetically engineered us and put us
here
so which in a sense is the same thing as
creationists are saying because they're
saying god poofed us here
and we didn't we didn't come from no
monkeys blah blah you know what
creationists do
but like i said for some reason it
doesn't piss me off as much when it's
aliens
i don't know i guess because it just
seems
not not as serious or i don't know i
don't know why it doesn't
it doesn't make me as bad but i don't
know
so um yeah i don't honestly like i said
we kind of covered most of the [ __ ]
about this
we're like three hours in what do you
want to talk about now no i guess that's
it where have you been
where do you mean where i've been oh you
were gone a long time yeah i made a
drink and i went through
it went to the restroom oh where did um
where did um pookie go she's right there
is she really yeah where are you folks
so that's it that was the uh the real
raelian show
the railing on the aliens really
kind of interesting i guess i mean
[ __ ] we should have had some pictures
well you know somebody said that but
it's just kind of like i don't know it's
just kind of like i don't know we we
used to do that but i
i kind of feel like because the show
before we did video
it used to be all pictures so i kind of
have like bad associations with like
having to look for like millions of
pictures of things
you know what i mean so sometimes i
don't really like think about it
because i'm just kind of like man [ __ ] i
imagine there were some [ __ ] bad ass
pictures we could have shown no
there's really not you know what there's
not a huge amount of information there's
a lot of information about them because
they
seem pretty um transparent about their
beliefs and stuff
uh they don't seem super secretive and
uh so they put all their [ __ ] pretty
much
right out there there's not like a ton
of pictures though
um you know there's some pictures of him
like in his little outfit
um you know there's some pictures of
like some you know hot girls and
there's like some stuff about the nudity
and whatnot because you know nudity and
aliens everybody's gonna want to like
hear about that [ __ ]
but like i said i kind of feel like
their big heyday came
in the early 2000s when they said hey we
cloned a baby
and that was kind of what everybody
heard about him and it was like yeah
[ __ ]
like i said maybe they did i don't know
but they didn't
they couldn't prove it so no one bought
it you know
um i'm not saying that it didn't happen
it probably didn't
but could they and honestly that was
2002.
i'd be surprised if someone hadn't
cloned a human by this time
you know what i mean yeah because that
was like such a long time ago and even
back then i was kind of like man well
maybe
they're probably cloning them in china
maybe they did
what if you could clone a baby if you
could well if you could genetically
engineer a baby
what what uh would you give it what
what aspect would you i would make it an
a boo
what the [ __ ] all right in the army oh
he's thought about this
okay yeah in the army they used to have
companies like alpha company i company
beast company c company
some of the some of the units are so big
that they ended with i all right
and usually these these little [ __ ]
um
companies would try to make a mascot
all right they had this crazy
[ __ ] in the 82nd airborne
division he was trying to come up and
he's the [ __ ]
first sergeant he's trying to come up
with a mascot
that beginning with an eye and the only
thing he could he's from with louisiana
you know the only thing he could come up
with is ibis but he think he sees the
ebbs he's like man [ __ ] that that's
[ __ ] weak
so he so he had to come up with his own
creature
it was the ibu okay
it was [ __ ] i company best unit ibu
it was a gorilla with an alligator tail
a a lion's head moose horns
and a parachute and a pistol and a
[ __ ]
jump boots and yeah you know when the
first when you said ibu the first thing
i thought of was international butt
umbrella
yeah okay well which would be a whole
different thing
later on that [ __ ] company that that
that company
got [ __ ] picked up and transferred
for the 101st and it
but that they made it an a company or
alpha company so he changed it to abel
and i was in that company for a while
abu company
so you guys can google it um so ask bud
umbrella
no alpha company best unit and if you
guys google abu
monster a b a boo monster all right just
google [ __ ] images you'll see it
that's a monster so what you do is you
take
a gorilla and you splice it with an
alligator
and a lion and you're gonna raise this
yeah
okay yeah training to be a
it's paratrooper a parachute on it oh it
has a natural parachute
yeah when you see it it's drawn with a
parachute on it and a [ __ ] pistol
and a [ __ ] dagger oh yeah yeah it's
got a book wow that's pretty good you
ever saw the movie
jacob's ladder there's a scene where
some vietnam veteran is shooting up in
the bathroom and they show his arm and
he's got tattooed on his arm an able
monster
oh [ __ ] i never noticed that yeah it's
an abu monster he was from my company
oh my god that's fine then i ended up in
a recon platoon after that but [ __ ]
yeah so
so if you could genetically engineer a
baby it would be enabled you would make
a gorilla with an alligator tail
that came equipped with a parachute and
a pistol and a [ __ ]
and a [ __ ] dagger and a dagger and it
has to have
right out the lion's head and a lion's
head i forgot with moosehorns
oh okay yeah it was has all the features
of all the most
badass [ __ ] creature is all combined
no no wings it doesn't need them because
it has a parachute
[Laughter]
it's got a joke though oh [ __ ]
it's got jump boots too okay i can't
believe you thought so much about this
well you asked me what i would make i
make a boom
[Laughter]
hey boo monster like i said so when the
okay so i'm going for like
practicalities here
when the able monster is a baby yeah
what does he eat
i don't know what do we feed the well we
need to figure this out if we're going
to raise the abbey monster to the abe
where's
okay this is this is tom's child this is
tom's dream child
it's an abu that's it it's a loss and
look he killed somebody from yeah it's
from the hunter first
[Laughter]
first three two seven infantry this abu
monster
you see you guys know what that special
forces and all this other [ __ ] but you
don't know about that
okay that's gonna we're gonna talk about
that on the cryptid show yeah i have to
put that in the poll
and the next week at times the able
monster looked like that
it's got a parachute and everything that
he looks like he's a little rough around
the edges there he's like man i'm so
[ __ ] tired
i've been abu monster in all day it's
just like i really can't deal with it
anymore i just
i didn't need a nap i can't believe he
doesn't have wings though he needs wings
he's got a parachute
does he have a kung fu grip no
no he can't even masturbate
how would you know that because he's got
no grip
see look don't show it to me show it to
them
i'll see it well i'll see it when you
put it up there that's that's how
videos that's when they dressed they
fancied him up hold on wait a second
oh wait he's got a suit on no no you
[ __ ] it up you [ __ ] it up
that shitty ass drawing in that foot in
the back of those that is clearly like
some people just took like some [ __ ]
clip art and just stuck it all together
without really thinking about how it's
gonna look
yeah i mean come on
we'll see okay i gotta write this down
because
we need to make an abu monster
yeah uh 13 o'clock design because i
could do a way better one than that yeah
okay
all right jesus christ yeah that's a
cryptid [ __ ] there's a cryptid for
you right here
i'm gonna write that down so one of
these days i'll get around to doing that
and then
and i'm gonna put your face on it except
for the lion's mane and then you wonder
why i smell
the way i smell yeah i'll show you that
picture that's what you're doing i don't
wonder
okay
phil says you're going to make me pee
again
sorry yeah i might pee too actually a
little thinking about it
what do you like to use is so funny i'm
laughing so hard who's gonna nurse this
creature
right he said he doesn't think about
that he only thinks about
ideas he doesn't like think about the
practicalities of the ideas like who the
hell is gonna have to like who the [ __ ]
is gonna raise this kid
yeah is this kid gonna eat everyone else
in kindergarten
like what is gonna be the issue yeah you
know what i'm saying
you nurse him on a you nurse him blood
no on pure c4 explosive that you [ __ ]
get
out of a [ __ ] damn 88 millimeter
mortar put and you [ __ ] like that you
put it
you unscrew the fuse off the impact fuse
that 88 millimeter and you put a [ __ ]
nipple
from a beaker front from a
from a bottle you put that on the end
there and you like that and
he'll sit there and he'll drink all that
c4 and get big
he'll grow to adulthood in a week well
that's handy yeah
he said you really thought a lot about
it and they speak in the louisiana
accent
okay that's cool you didn't know that
either his father was from louisiana so
he'll only be around for a week and then
he'll be out on his own
oh yeah he'll be around for a week and
he's on his own like the jim hedar from
[ __ ] star trip
they grew up fast you they don't need
intelligence or experience it's just
pure instinct
that makes sense yeah purity oh my god
how funny would that be
if i did like an avon monster with your
face on it
it's got to have a lion's head on it
well now we can have a lion's mane
but i can still kind of make it look
like you i could still kind of make it
look like you
that would be well it'd be way funnier
than just like a generic it's gotta have
pants on and [ __ ] jump boots yeah
parachute okay gotta respect you gotta
respect a monster that wears pants
yes and shoes
yeah he's the polite monster well i
don't want to like upset anybody with
all
the stuff that like sticking out you
know what i mean
all right we're going to shut it down
you sure yeah it's kind of like well
yeah we've been on for like
three hours it's not forever it's like
three hours and 15 minutes calm down
yeah
yeah we didn't even drink i've only got
my second drink but like
there's that's the last of the booze
yeah man we might have to like go out
tomorrow and get booze
i don't know we don't have any more in
the house could always go out tonight
guys go to mannequins what time is it
nine nine o'clock
tonight's the bloodbath i don't know if
they're continuing it tomorrow because
tonight's graham's birthday you know
graham
yeah uh it's the bloodbath for his
birthday tonight
i don't know man i'm so [ __ ] sleepy
well if you're sleepy then we
shouldn't go i mean like i said i've
been up since quarter to six why did i
wake up at quarter six i don't [ __ ]
know but i did
and uh i tried to go back to sleep and i
couldn't so i've been up since
then and it's like as soon as the show
started i thought i was gonna like
because my eyes were going like that but
somebody says what is bloodbath it's um
yeah they do well they did it um they do
it at like lots of different like goth
industrial clubs it's basically you just
come there like covered with blood
like yeah like okay you used to wear a
white and stuffed a bunch of blood
like carry at the end of carry like
somebody dumped blood on you
yeah uh i went to one several years ago
at
middle knocked yeah when that was at eye
bar
i didn't put any that much blood on but
it's like by the end of the night like
so many people hugged me and stuff i was
just like i was so [ __ ] sticky
everything was sticky and dyed red it
was fun though
but yeah so they're doing that tonight
that was that was graham's request for
his birthday he wanted to do bloodbath i
did the poster for it
the poster came out nice yeah i will say
that
yeah they're they're on their man to uh
to [ __ ] uh garcia
and um and uh who was that
what it was uh trying to see who it was
i don't know what he was talking about
man he was like wait it was mango badger
i think or uh
or was it mega badger
no i can't remember who it was
[Laughter]
all the [ __ ] all the cards lined up
because in the upper management
i [ __ ] got i [ __ ] got good
contacts in disney you know where we
live
yeah and rangers the new republic is
[ __ ] coming back too
yeah she's back are you going cry all
you want but that's how that [ __ ] really
rolls they go for money
they only care about money they don't
care about you they care about money
all right they also don't care about
right and wrong
or what you think right and wrong is
you're told what's right and wrong
anyway
you think you've compiled it out of your
own opinions but they control what
opinions you have and the data that you
have
they don't give a [ __ ] don't give a [ __ ]
it's all about money but now she's
coming back
i love that woman jenny loves that woman
too
she can [ __ ] kick man she's [ __ ]
she's cool she's cool she's very cool
yeah i mean you're saying well she said
this and she didn't [ __ ] say anything
you could twist anything to make
anything and read it anything she she
didn't give a [ __ ] about that nobody
else cared either
it's all culture war and really culture
wars don't end until
[ __ ] one side is dead so we're just
gonna see what's gonna happen
this shit's gonna go bad it's gonna go
down
and i don't really have a dog in the
fight i'd give a [ __ ] i could leave here
i fought for this country once i will
never fight for this [ __ ] again i don't
care i fight for my people now
her my family and my friends
i don't care about anything else what
about pookie
[Laughter]
i'm gonna let you all [ __ ] kill
each other over stupid [ __ ] no it's good
and then i'm gonna collect
all your [ __ ] after you're dead it's
gonna all be mine
i'm gonna say oh okay yeah that's mine
that's mine that's mine that's mine
because i got the point where i don't
believe in anything well it'll be really
easy because you've made all those
clones of yourself
that are that are going to take pregnant
all the damn survivors anyway
so everybody's going to be my child
and then there'll be people and then and
then the aliens will come out
on earth it came all the way back it
would be piece of ass on earth
everywhere oracle said what about
beijing yeah beijing too
yeah i know i feel bad because
well she's like older and like i said
she's kind of like aloof
yeah so it's like we try to be nice to
her but she's like [ __ ] off
i don't like you sometimes
it's much it's you know it's much easier
to be like oh pokey because she's always
like in your face
you know yeah
[Laughter]
oh keep wanting something vic is going
on i'll remind you every month when
she's not back
well it's going to be a while because
they got to do a bunch of filming but
she's been down there dude
she's been down there at the studio
don't worry okay that's all i'm gonna
say no one no one's worried
yeah um yeah she's been down there wait
somebody said gran there's hammer said
if someone went to mannequins covered in
real human blood would anyone know
um probably not
i probably shouldn't tell people that
but i don't know
i was kind of thinking about it because
i was like oh i feel bad like not going
but
if i had slept later this morning i
would probably be up for going but i'm
so [ __ ] sleepy that it's like i don't
think that i could
i mean i haven't even really drank that
much but so i'm not drunk but
i'm just so [ __ ] sleepy that i don't
know if i could like okay
phil would come in trying to stir up the
pot again okay so this creature that tom
is making
can it have sex of course the of course
the abu maya
tom wouldn't make a creature that was
this thing is
[ __ ] hung like a fire extinguisher of
course tom is making this
do you remember who you think weapon i'm
talking about weaponized [ __ ] penis
weaponized penis i'm gonna have zach in
does it have spikes on it i'mma hire in
zach as a professional consultant
uh uh to help me [ __ ] genetically
design just the penis alone
i'm gonna have gay input and have this
habit about the shape and gay input yeah
zach's gonna tell me how it should be
shaped that's another that's another
good band name
yeah yeah hi we're gay input yeah yeah
that's like the third good band name
i've come up with tonight
you just gotta let this [ __ ] [ __ ] no
um
no the evil monster is [ __ ] it's
gendered it it it is male
yeah it it smells like you
oh look man [ __ ] it's even worse
because
every pretty much worse than you get
worse because
it's a gorilla all right it's the base
creature is a gorilla
and every time i've [ __ ] seen like an
accurate drawing of the abu monster
it's obviously it's obvious to me that
that gorilla's roided out
all right so he's gonna [ __ ] stink
you know he's gonna [ __ ] stink he's
like he's like super testosterone he's
[ __ ] coming out
it's it's gorilla steroids it's the
steroids that you use on a gorilla
but will he have a wig
he doesn't need a wig because
he doesn't need one because he has a
lion's mane
it's it's he's got his own natural wig
[Laughter]
how about a hat can he have a hat yeah
he can have a hat
i think it's a military style hat but
he's usually not
how about a viking helmet no no because
he already has horns
he's got moose antlers you didn't notice
that
oh yeah it's a lion it's a [ __ ] check
this out
you all are civilians and you can't
grasp greatness when you see it
oh that must be what it takes a while
for it to all
sink in when you have that much bad ass
phil says can you make a gay one
yeah yeah yeah yeah you could you could
it's don't ask don't tell policy
you don't know what what what it doesn't
really matter it's not it's not really
it's not really um that's not it's
sexual orientation
is is unclear okay with all the drug
but when you see an abu monster it's a
gorilla
and that gorilla is on steroids it's got
a [ __ ] alligator tail
it's wearing jump boots and a [ __ ]
parachute it's got a [ __ ] alliance
head
with moose antlers and it's carrying a
pistol and a dagger
so and it's not just any old dagger it's
a [ __ ] bayonet
it's got moose antlers okay it's got
it's
[Laughter]
regular horns are not good enough i'm
just mad because he doesn't have wings
that's all
it's got a parachute but it's not really
the same thing
[Music]
it doesn't need to fly it's got a c-130
or a c5 galaxy that it jumps out
it has an invisible plane like wonder
woman no it's just it's got a military
plane the army flies it wherever it
needs to be
it just jumps out you know it doesn't
mean
it's got a lot better it's got a [ __ ]
plane it's got either got a c-130 we
could do a whole show
just about this monster this was thought
up a long time ago
but by men more crazy than i one man
crazier than i it was the first sergeant
from louisiana
came up with that [ __ ] his name is
[ __ ] written down here i forgot what
his name was
they said he was [ __ ] crazy you know
and it's
stuck he came up with that [ __ ] because
there wasn't anything cool that started
with an eye and then that cut then that
got unit got turned it got sent to the
hunter first it became an a company
so he just changed it from ibu to a boo
because there wasn't anything that
started with a that was good either
he was going to call it like asp but
then you know like asp
but everyone thought it was like that
sounds like an ass yeah
so the ass monster that's a totally so
it just became
alpha company best unit abu
abu abu monster he just made it up his
own
creature abu or ibu
but even that sounds pretty lame i gotta
say he was drinking
i just cut the dude some slack yeah
i just find it funny that you that y'all
are [ __ ] mystified by this because we
would have talked about this in the army
for like two minutes and then moved on
because it would be like yo yeah we just
would have taken it accepted it as a
fact
well yeah but kids had that tattooed on
them and that's just showed up in
jason's
jacob's ladder i know yeah
you said that already yeah well no just
like well when somebody comes up with a
concept like that i like to
you know i like to unpack that a little
bit i like to delve a little bit deeper
into that
yeah you know what i mean make you like
think about
the parameters of what we're talking
about it was just something that they
that they had and that like you know
outside the company area they'd [ __ ]
have you know
that painted on a wall it's kind of like
the paintings of the [ __ ] the colored
one like stuff like that
not that lame one how [ __ ] not that lame
one
we back in my day i mean that was pretty
lame
yeah that was like i said that was like
hey we found like just some dude
cheap ass clip art and we just like
[ __ ] slapped a lion head on it yeah
you know okay so how awesome would it be
if somebody
like some budding michelangelo out there
did like a whole ceiling with the abu
monster
like on the ceiling but he did it like
all renaissance style
you can picture it that would be awesome
right yeah i would think
you know how big his bed would have to
be
see we're like thinking of like all the
practicalities
because the whole reason you came up
with that was because somebody asked
because i asked you if you could
genetically engineer a child
what would you come up with and that was
what you came up with and that's why
everyone's asking you questions about it
because like if you were raising it
gilbert's asking does it use a toilet
does it wipe its
ass does it need a diaper no it [ __ ]
shits in the woods just like regular
soldier
like a bear it wipes it wipes its ass
with mre [ __ ] toilet paper
yeah mr robot i said did jenny get a
haircut yeah i did
well i had i did i had this part shaved
back here
like i had a mohawk um but i still had
this hair
like here in the front and then like
last night i was like [ __ ] it i'm not
really doing anything with this so i
shaved it all off and i shaved off all
underneath here too so actually so i
still have the top of my hair it's not a
wig this is my actual
hair um so all of this is shaved like in
the back
it's much much cooler because it's
florida i had it like this like a long
time ago
yeah and then it took like a couple
years and it grew all back out but then
last night i was like [ __ ] it i'm just
like sick of
so much hair saying i'm getting all
those doom
i don't know how i'm getting all those
doom but
does its poop stick to its fur probably
because i have to say poor beijing
pookie does not have this problem
because pookie is short hair
beijing is a rag doll and so she has
really long hair and she has especially
long hair right around her butt
so sometimes when she goes to use the
facilities
um little little poop sticks on her fur
and then she kind of carries it out and
sometimes we find little she falls on
the [ __ ]
little turd like on the floor she
doesn't mean to
because she thinks that she squats down
in the in the thing and poops and then
like but no it's really like still
attached to the bird it's
like got the litter box in the in the um
in the laundry room in the laundry room
so it's tile
so it always lands on the tile anyway
yeah i don't think i've ever found it on
the carpet
it usually doesn't get that far because
usually i'll go in there to do the
laundry and i'll be like oh
be like a couple feet from the cat box
there's like a little turtle
yeah she doesn't mean to one time she
was taking a dump in the middle of a
thunderstorm and when the lightning hit
she jumped out of the cav box and turned
[ __ ] fell on the floor well that was
pooky
yeah it's pokey oh yeah yeah yeah not
beijing yeah
that was the only time that pokey like
somewhere
that she missed the cat box she was and
that was she was a little she was like a
kitten yeah the lightning bolt got her
yeah she was in there like doing it and
she was like
she jumped out and like a little turn
away
i felt so bad for her and she's looking
out what is going on
oh my god she was so little i think she
was only like
six or eight weeks old at that point but
yeah she was a baby
so it's like i felt so bad i said man i
hope she's not like traumatized about
using actually
nobody but she did yeah i thought she
didn't want to be traumatized about
using it
but yeah so like i said you know beijing
sometimes poops outside but she doesn't
need to it just like sticks to her
buffer and she doesn't realize that it's
back there
that it kind of like falls off a couple
feet what size waste
or will you have to have his clothes
made i don't know who he's talking about
must be talking about the uh
the um the abu monster
oh yeah maybe i don't know well he only
wear he only had pants right
he just had pants yeah he didn't wear a
shirt he just wears a [ __ ]
parachute well why does he even need
pants because he has fur
he's got to wear a uniform you have to
know that he's in the army
oh okay he's got jump boots on too so
you know he's a paratrooper
yeah i still kind of feel like he
probably have to have his clothes
tailored i'm just saying
his waist is about like 26 it's real
[ __ ] small
but his [ __ ] his his upper body is
[ __ ] huge
it's like a huge he's gorilla
proportions
but voided out gorilla like you couldn't
get a shirt for him
no so can he talk or does he do sign
language
they can't like coco they can't talk
they didn't do side language just shoot
people
yeah he doesn't give a [ __ ] what you're
saying he's just gonna shoot you
no they don't talk make a horror movie
about that
make a word about that [ __ ]
getting killed by the strange monster i
don't know what it is somewhere
seriously though look it up and probably
somebody's already made one
no nobody knows what abu is you sure
yeah only paratroopers know what abu
is yeah but those people like know that
have friends and family members that
might make a horror movie too
the only time i ever saw it portrayed in
a movie was in jacob's ladder
a guy had a tattoo of a boo it was a
good tattoo
of a boo monster too i better find it i
don't know
i don't know if anybody's put a picture
of that up on the internet but um
internet has everything yeah but uh
no what you do is you make a horror
movie about some dudes up in europe
getting killed by some monster they
don't know what it is but it turns out
it was a
blue leftover from [ __ ] world war ii
and they're fighting it kind of like
it's krampus
[Laughter]
and it does [ __ ] [ __ ] it does all
kinds of cool [ __ ]
and you have to explain why it's can we
please put that on the poster we'll call
it abu monster
it does shift yeah that'll be the
tagline
it does [ __ ] you have to have like
southern inflection abu monster
it does [ __ ] that's like says it all you
know
i could make a [ __ ] movie that would
appeal to 12 year old boys across the
[ __ ] gap
across the whole [ __ ] galaxy it would
just be nothing but badassery through
the whole thing it's just
ludicrous badassery ludicrous ludicrous
badassery i kind of feel like that will
be written on your tombstone
you could you could set the whole thing
back in world war
ii that it was a world war ii [ __ ]
secret weapon
that might be even better actually yeah
that you mentioned it yeah
and it was fighting people's fighting
germans and fighting the nazis or
something
no that's too typical everybody's
fighting tonight yeah it's like that's
yeah that's like that's
you have it fighting you have it
fighting the italians or you have it
fighting the japanese
something like that can we have a
monster versus like godzilla
you can [ __ ] work well you could have
something where it's it's it's
could he get big like big man japan yeah
you might be able to do something like
that
like the japanese have a response to it
all right
it's like a [ __ ] large turtle or
something
we'll call it gamma they'll take care of
this problem
like a gaggle of kenny's yeah
yeah little kitties with their tiny
shorts
they'll all be riding on games little
sexualized japanese boys
yeah i kind of i like this movie
somebody needs to get on the screen play
like to tweet
[Laughter]
you have to have that [ __ ] set in the
[ __ ] into a realistic setting
actually i think i think abu might have
started sometime in the vietnam era
so you'd probably have to put it in
vietnam probably make more sense
i feel like there's not a lot of horror
movies
about vietnam in the vietnam which would
probably be like a [ __ ] up thing to do
but i mean honestly
there's a lot of horror movies like set
in world war
ii well you see there's a [ __ ]
there's something
you can do here all right where you
wouldn't even have
you you wouldn't even i'm saying this
[ __ ] in public see and i shouldn't be
talking about it cause i'm gonna steal
the idea
well it's not like well you're not gonna
do it so that's true
go ahead and make this [ __ ] i wanna see
it there's the abu monster
secret weapon abu monster in vietnam and
it starts [ __ ] up the [ __ ] viet
cong so bad that
that that the nva [ __ ]
goes to their allies the en the um
the the dprk there was north korea and
asked them for help
and north korea has a [ __ ] secret
weapon
as a response it's a [ __ ] it's a
[ __ ]
ancient creature that they've kept in
storage since the middle ages
since the since the since the north
korean middle ages is called pugasari
yeah is the north korean godzilla
they actually did make that yeah and he
starts off small see
and he grows with with the more metal
that he eats
yeah so there's a time in which the
pugusario they call him pugosario
pulsario and [ __ ] um the ava
the monster would be about about the
same size see
and during that time during that
timeframe see
abu the abu monster has to get he has to
get a [ __ ] hold of him
before he gets too big
yeah so then there's like
yeah you don't want it to get too big so
then there's like there's like a sexual
thing about who's bigger than who
they have like a dick off and [ __ ]
whose dick is bigger or whatever i don't
know we'll come up with something that's
just [ __ ] crazy like it'll be like
dusk
maybe that level of crazy
it's like tusk in vietnam but with
monsters
there's your elevator pitch right there
yeah
[Laughter]
see let me make these [ __ ] paying the
wrong people for this [ __ ]
i don't know tom's just like sitting
back going you're welcome
watch them [ __ ] take that [ __ ] and
they make millions of dollars
it rivals joker at the box
and it's a indie flick they keep all the
money [ __ ]
they don't give me anything well you
should probably write it down and like
mail it to yourself or something so you
get like so if you have to sue them you
can prove that you do
the idea no i got the proof right here
although yeah we actually have the
proofread because it's dated and
everything so see
you did it you just copyrighted the idea
so now if anybody takes it
like you can do it but then like maybe
we'll sue you though like if you make
the movie and keep all the money
so i think you like you know you can
make the movie but if you make like a
billion dollars just like cut us off of
a little chunk of change
pokey stop tearing [ __ ] off what's she
doing i don't know she's trying to dig
through the books
there's nothing back there pookie
narnia's not back there it's not in the
closet it's not behind the books it's
not anywhere
okay i hate to tell you i'm sleepy
all right yeah we've been on for like
three and a half hours so that's okay so
i mean we talked about stuff
most of the time yeah that's fine all
right so uh
anyway we will be back on sunday
afternoon
we're going to be talking about 310 to
yuma are we not
okay yeah okay because we just watched
that uh
so yeah so that'll be sunday so have a
good
weekend up until we see you sunday
afternoon
thank you everybody for dropping by
thanks for all your super chats thanks
for all the awesome conversation
and we will see you guys on sunday and
hey check it out i have an actual outro
so we'll see you guys on sunday bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you